Ich bin ein bisschen schrecklich, dass die Leute das nicht sehen.
Erst mal Hallo, herzlich willkommen und viel Spaß in den nächsten drei Stunden hier bei Fritz. Chaos Radio heute auch wieder weltweit live zu hören übers Internet nämlich per Real Audio. Wer das tun möchte oder wer vielleicht seinen Freunden oder Bekannten jetzt noch schnell eine E-Mail schicken will und sagen will, hier hör mal rein, der braucht eigentlich nur www.fritz.de eingeben bzw. angeben und von da gibt es einen direkten Link auf das Live-Programm per Real Audio. Der Chaos Computer Club heute zu viert in Oldschool-Besetzungen, richtig. Hier müssen wir mal wieder Mikrochecks machen am Anfang, wie das so üblich ist.
Das geht hier nicht.
Das geht hier nicht. Ist das echt an?
Na dafür checken wir, dass wir das einsprechen.
Ah, siehst du, das Internet läuft auch schon.
Geht doch alles.
Internet läuft auch schon.
Kann man das bei dir hören? Das Internet?
Was kann man bei mir hören? Ähm, ja, gute Idee.
Dann kann ich es doch mit dir selber unterhalten.
Oh ja, lass uns mal einen abgefahrenen Feedback erzeugen.
Der Akku. Das war mein Handy. D07.
Mach mal lieber aus.
Wir warten mal, was da passiert ist.
Aber wir haben schon wieder wunderbare Badezimmer, Klo, Hallatmosphäre hier.
Ist das immer sobald...
Ist das irgendwas zu laut?
Nee, das ist einfach sobald hier vier Mikros auf sind, die nebeneinander sind. Hast du halt viel Raumklang mit zu.
Wie heißt die Klautin, das wäre so eine große Raumklang.
Wer bringt uns die Hand?
Waschraumklang, genau.
Sag mal, von wem kommt die Musik heute?
Die kommt vom Analog Club, das DJ-Team, das immer noch am Leben ist, auch wenn die Leute vom NBI irgendwie ein Rad abhaben und da irgendwie Verstimmung gab. Aber Analog Club geht weiter und...
Ansonsten ist das Thema heute, auf das wir gleich eingehen, nachdem wir die Intro-Formalitäten erledigt haben. Klingt auch wie aus dem Badezimmer, wir können ja gleich noch mal gucken, ob wir das ein bisschen besser hinkriegen. Das Thema heute lautet Kryptographie und Privatsphäre. Und zwar eure Privatsphäre und unsere natürlich auch. Vorher aber noch ein paar einleitende Sätze. Vielleicht erstmal wer hier ist heute vom CCC.
Ja, ich muss ja wohl den Bademeister spielen in dieser Halle.
Von links nach rechts, du weißt doch, wie das geht.
Gut. Ich bin der Andi.
Der Andreas.
Hier ist Frank.
Und Tim. Wie unser Dank.
Unser Bademeister.
Meister, ich dachte so.
Nicht vom Becken ran, spring da hinten!
Wir sind eine Woche verschoben.
Ja, ich spür's auch im Kreuz.
Was hast du gemacht letzte Woche?
Das darf ich dir nicht sagen. Ich hatte Geburtstag.
Hmm, nachträglich.
Und was hast du gemacht letzte Woche?
Ich hab das hier schon ausgebreitet, hab schon schlechte spanische Musik gespielt, die ich mitgebracht hab und so. Ich hab eine Woche Urlaub gemacht. Das ist das erste Mal seit, weiß ich nicht, vier Jahren.
Ich bin unglaublich braun und entspannt auf der Sonne.
Du sollst dir langsam meine Webcam aufstellen, glaube ich. Jetzt kommt unser eigenes Programm Peri Audio.
Was bist du jetzt?
Ja, das Problem ist nur, dass, du weißt schon...
Also das Internet ist toll, das macht aus einem Badezimmer eine Mülltonne.
Wann werden wir einen 100 Megawatt Anschluss hier haben?
Naja, geht doch.
Naja, also...
Die entscheidende Frage ist, weil die Leute endlich dahinter kommen, dass man Multicasting nehmen muss, wenn man Radio im Internet machen möchte.
Was heißt denn das?
Na, das heißt, dass du nicht an jeden Hörer einen einzelnen Stream schickst, sondern einen Stream an alle, damit du nicht für 3000 Leute 3000 Abbandbreite brauchst, denn nur einmal.
Und wie kann dann jeder trotzdem zu einem anderen Zeitpunkt hören?
Na, das geht natürlich nicht, aber ich mein, gerade haben wir ja die Situation, dass die Leute das live hören möchten.
Dieser Datt ist unheimlich leise.
Naja, aber irgendwann ist Schluss. Bisschen unterpegelt.
Analog unterpegelt.
Es ist irgendwie das Mischpult bei Maria gewesen, weil die haben irgendwie keinen Datt-Ausgang, sondern wir haben den Monitor-Ausgang nehmen müssen. Und den wiederum haben wir trotzdem mit den Monitor-Boxen mit treiben müssen. Und da wir die nicht so weit haben wollten, ist das alles eine Katastrophe.
Das war der heilige Tod.
Kein Product Pleasure mehr.
Ich hab irgendwie den Snort in meinem System, glaube ich, gerade. Wie immer.
Kann passieren.
Lass uns ein bisschen in die Dat reinhören und dann gibt's noch ein paar Worte zur Verschwindungssendung.
Ich bin ich. Bin ich wohl wieder auf Sender? Ja, die Sache ist die, wir wollten jetzt nochmal zwei, drei Worte dazu sagen, dass wir in Chaos Radio letzten Monat bzw. letzte Woche ausgefallen sind. Das hängt halt unmittelbar. Dann haben wir zusammen das Mitte letzten Monats, eines unserer Mitglieder, der Tron, unser Chipkartenhacker, ja zunächst verschwand und dann später tot aufgefunden wurde, um nicht zu sagen umgebracht wurde. Das hat uns alle, ja sowohl persönlich als auch organisatorisch, relativ fest erstmal erschüttert, weil das so weder geplant beabsichtigt noch absehbar war und wir dann auch erstmal A und auch immer noch eine Menge damit zu tun haben, herauszufinden, was da eigentlich passiert ist und B dann auch irgendwie noch die Weltpresse an den Haken hatten und die erstmal wieder loswerden mussten. Deswegen gibt es auch hier jetzt erstmal nur eine kurze Erläuterung zu dem Fall. Wir haben halt gesagt, wir möchten im Moment, um die Ermittlungen nicht zu beeinträchtigen, keine richtigen Informationen rausgeben. Wir werden auf unserem Kongress, da kommen wir später noch zu, der ja zwischen Weihnachten und Neujahr und nicht zu sagen in vier Wochen ist hier in Berlin, da ein bisschen mehr zu sagen, was da eigentlich abgegangen ist. Und haben halt im Internet bei uns auf der Homepage abrufbar auch eine kleine Presseerklärung dazu, die so ein bisschen grob umreißt, in was für einem Spannungsfeld er sich da befand. Und was da möglicherweise schief gegangen ist.
Die Ermittlungen in dieser Geschichte laufen aber weiter?
Die laufen weiter, sowohl polizeilich als auch außerpolizeilich. Es ist halt von Nord aus zu gehen.
Soviel Sätze dazu, das soll reichen für jetzt. Und Andy hat es gerade schon angesprochen, es gibt noch ein anderes Intro-Thema, nämlich den Chaos Communication Congress nach Jahren. Dieses Jahr endlich mal wieder in Berlin. Nicht in Hamburg, wie sonst immer. Und Tim ist im Stress.
Ja, ich glaube wir sind alle gerade ein bisschen im Stress, was den Kongress betrifft, aber das ist auch völlig normal, weil das ist eigentlich jedes Jahr so. Insofern, als er vor 5 Jahren schon mal in Berlin war.
So lange ist das her.
Ja, es war der 10. Kongress, der halt in Berlin war. Und jetzt ist es der 15. Das verfolgt keine Absicht. Es ist nur so, dass der Kongress in den letzten 2 Jahren deutlich an Publikumsinteresse angeschwollen ist. Und im letzten Jahr, nicht zuletzt durch die hervorragenden Workshops von Tron, war das Interesse schon echt überwältigend. Am Anfang hatten wir mal einen Raum, das war unser Hackcenter. Da war dann irgendwie alles voll mit Computern. Und im letzten Jahr haben wir gedacht, naja, das Interesse ist doch irgendwie gestiegen. Dann nehmen wir mal zwei. Im Endeffekt war halt auch noch der ganze Flur voll. Und die Workshops waren einfach komplett, also es war einfach alles total voll mit Menschen. Und zwar, die Kongressatmosphäre fing halt langsam an drunter zu leiden. Und dann haben wir uns halt umgeschaut. Und in Berlin was sehr Schönes gefunden, das Haus am Kölnischen Park, so ein Tagungszentrum in Berlin-Mitte, was ganz hervorragende Voraussetzungen für unseren Kongress bietet. Dort werden wir uns endlich mal in dem Maße entfalten können, wie das uns schon immer vorgeschwebt hat. Ansonsten bleibt alles gleich, der Termin. 27. bis 29. Dezember, also gleich nach Weihnachten. Hecke haben ja eigentlich sowieso mit Weihnachten nicht so viel am Hut. Von daher ist das schon immer unser Termin gewesen.
Ja, und vielleicht um noch mal ein, zwei Worte für diejenigen zu sagen, die den Kongress nicht kennen, weil du hast da eben schon so einen Begriff verwendet, den ich irgendwie nicht so klasse finde, weil es ist ja nicht Publikum, das wir da erwarten, sondern Kongress besteht im Wesentlichen daraus, dass wir da drei Tage die Räume haben. Wir haben zwei Workshop-Räume, wir haben eine Aula, wir haben Marktsender, wir haben Chaos-Café und im Wesentlichen lebt der Kongress halt davon, dass die Leute da nicht hingehen, um sich irgendetwas zu konsumieren, sondern um eben aktiv miteinander sich auszutauschen, Themen zu diskutieren und zwar nicht nur jetzt auf der technischen Bandbreite, wo wir eben bemüht sind, Referenten zusammenzukriegen und auch selbst ein bisschen jeweils, wo sich wer auskennt, eben zu berichten, was sich da technisch vivo getan hat, wie was funktioniert und auch einleitende Themen zu IP-Protokollgeschichten und fast nicht allem zu geben, sondern eben auch gesellschaftliche Folgen von technologischer Entwicklung, nicht nur in Bezug auf Überwachungssysteme, Immer aber eben auf zunehmende Datenmengen, die anfallen im Bezug auf Abhängigkeiten, die von Technologie abstehen und so weiter und so fort. Also wie sich eigentlich die Menschen mit diesen Maschinen so einlassen und was daraus wird.
Und gleichzeitig ist dieser so ein Kongress auch die beste Möglichkeit, Gleichgesinnte oder Gleichdenkende oder auch Andersdenkende, aber mit sich mit ähnlichen Materien, sich beschäftigende Leute kennenzulernen. Es kommen oft an chaos.orb.de E-Mails, wo drin steht, wo ich immer nicht sicher bin, ob die ernst gemeint sind, wo drin steht. Bitte sagt mir, wie ich Hacker werde. Oder so eine Geschichte.
Kommt mittlerweile auch an chaos.orb.de.
Und es ist natürlich völlig klar, dass man darauf keine Antwort geben kann, sondern gut ist, wenn ihr... Okay, aber viele von diesen Fragen kann man dann auf den Kongress stellen, und zwar den, der neben einem sitzt am besten.
Naja, also wir haben das organisatorisch, was unsere E-Mails betrifft, so gelöst. Es gibt zwar auch eine FAQ, und da steht aber sehr wenig drin, sondern die Anfragen gehen in so einen Anfragenverteiler. Da lesen also etwa 150 Leute die Anfragen mit. Und das heißt, es kann einem passieren, wenn man da eine Anfrage hinschickt, dann kriegt man ungefähr 15 verschiedene Antworten, und zwar nicht nur 15 verschiedene Antworten, sondern auch völlig 15 unterschiedliche Aussagen zu einer Frage, wo sozusagen die gesamte Bandbreite möglicherweise abgedeckt ist und wir uns immerhin damit erfolgreich davon drucken können, irgendeine Frage eindeutig beantworten zu müssen, weil das ist ja ein langweiliges Spießergeschäft.
Was man vielleicht noch sagen sollte, ist, dass jeder dringendst aufgefordert ist, auch seinen Rechner zum Kongress mitzubringen. Also wir werden da Internet haben und wir werden halt auch ein Kongressnetzwerk haben, wo alle Leute ihren Rechner anschließen können über das Ethernet.
Die Stromverteiler nicht vergessen.
Ja, Strom wird es auch geben, sodass Hubs bringt Hubs mit.
Genau, und Mehrfachsteckdosen.
Und wir werden auch einen FTP-Server haben und wir werden einen Web-Server haben und wir werden jede Menge lustige weitere Server haben. Ihr seid natürlich selbstverständlich auch eingeladen, eure eigenen Server dort zu betreiben.
Bringt CD-Brenner mit. Massig. Bringt alle CD-Brenner mit. Es wird einen enormen Bedarf an Duplikationsmöglichkeiten geben und den können wir natürlich alleine nicht decken. Ansonsten Informationen gibt es zum Kongress jetzt schon unter www.ccc.de slash Kongress. Das spielt auch immer weiter an und es wird auch gerade in den nächsten Tagen weiter zunehmendes Informationsangebot wird ungefähr in einer Woche auch schon den ersten Fahrplan, so nennen wir unser Programm, geben. Und es gibt eine sehr umfangreiche FAQ, die auch gerade die Fragen beantwortet mit was brauche ich, wenn ich da einen Computer haben will, wie baue ich das auf, wann ist der Kongress, wo kann ich pennen und so weiter. Also diese ganzen Informationen findet man dort.
Also bevor ihr uns jetzt anruft und uns irgendwelche Sachen zum Kongress fragt, erst die FAQ lesen.
Genau, erst die FAQ lesen. Die ist zumindest so lang, dass die Sendung dann vorbei ist.
Also wie immer, wie hier ist die schöne Abkürzung, RTFM, lesen Sie bitte die ausführliche Gebrauchsanweisung, ganz frei übersetzt. Das Ganze unter www.ccc.de slash Kongress mit K.
Nein, das ist doch der CCC.
Na ja, aber trotzdem.
Johnny, du bist nicht bald ab.
Mensch, denk doch ein bisschen an unsere corporate identity.
Ich bin ein bisschen müde.
Wir haben ja noch Clubmate, ja, Johnny.
Clubmate?
Das gibt es auch auf dem Kongress und das hilft, das macht müde Hacker munter.
Da trinke ich jetzt mal einen Schluck von. Da ist übrigens kein Alkohol drin, falls ihr euch das jetzt fragt. Na ja, wie ist es? Marte, Tee und?
Koffein und Zucker.
Koffein, Zucker, alles was gut ist für die Zähne. Und wir hören uns nach den Fritz Kurz Info gleich wieder. Und dann geht es auch schon los mit unserem Thema heute, nämlich Kryptographie und Privatsphäre hier im Chaos Radio bei Fritz. Im Internet-Chat bei Fritz kam gerade die Anfrage übrigens auch zu finden unter www.fritz.de slash speakers dann. So lautet die Adresse, wir sind im Studio-Chat, zumindest ist das im www.so.es, gibt aber auch einen Tellnet-Chat, sagen wir gleich alles noch mal genau an und das kam gerade die Frage, von wem die Musik ist. Wer das jetzt genau ist als Künstler, wissen wir gar nicht genau, das ganze kommt vom Analog-Club-DJ-Team und das muss euch erst mal reichen. Das sind so Betriebsgeheimnisse. Das sind so Betriebsgeschichten.
Wenn Fritz im Raum Angermünde, dann 100, 1.
Hier ist er.
22.31 Uhr.
Richtungsbestimmungen. Spitzenpolitiker von SPD und Bündnisgrün sind an Abend zu ihrer ersten Koalitionsrunde zusammengekommen. Bei dem Gespräch geht es unter anderem um eine bessere Abstimmung ihrer Regierungspolitik. Beide Seiten wollen Streitigkeiten über die Steuerpolitik und die 620 Marktjobs ausräumen. Reaktion. Israel hat am Abend erneut den vereinbarten Truppenabzug aus dem Westjordanland gestoppt. Die Regierung begründete die Entscheidung mit dem Angriff einer palästinensischen Menge auf einen israelischen Soldaten bei Ramallah. Der Truppenabzug werde erst dann fortgesetzt, wenn die Palästinenserführung von der Ausrufung eines eigenen Staates im Mai kommenden Jahresabsehe hieß es. Bahnvorhaben. Die Deutsche Bahn will im nächsten Jahr bis zu 18.000 Arbeitsplätze streichen. Dies bestätigte Konzernchef Ludewig heute nach einer Aufsichtsratssitzung in Berlin. Das Gremium hatte zuvor ein neues Programm für mehr Pünktlichkeit und besseren Service gebilligt. Marschroute. Das Bundeskabinett hat heute Ziele der deutschen Europapolitik beraten. Deutschland übernimmt am 1. Januar die Ratspräsidentschaft der Europäischen Union. Hauptvorhaben ist ein Beschäftigungspakt, um die Zahl der zurzeit 18 Millionen Arbeitslosen in den EU-Mitgliedsstaaten zu senken. Fahndungserfolg. Die von der NATO geführte SV-Truppe in Bosnien hat den Serben General Krzysztycz festgenommen. Krzysztycz werden Verbrechen gegen die Menschlichkeit im Zusammenhang mit der gefallenen bosnischen Moslem-Enklave Srebrenica vorgeworfen. Fußball im Viertelfinale des DFB-Pokals verlor Zweitligist Tennis Brussia bei Werder Bremen 1 zu 2 nach Verlängerung. Zweitligist Rot-Weiß Oberhausen bezwang Brussia Mönchengladbach 2 zu 0. Der VfL Wolfburg gewann gegen die Sportfreunde Siegen 3 zu 1. Bereits gestern zog Bayern München ins Halbfinale.
Wette.
Heute Nacht bedeckt etwa Schneegriesel bei minus 6 bis minus 10 Grad. Morgen meist heiter und trocken. Temperaturen minus 5 bis minus 1 Grad.
Verkehr.
A10 Richtung Dreieck Schwanebek zwischen Felden und Birkenwerder ist die rechte Spur wegen Bergungsarbeiten gesperrt und L3 und 37 von der A12 in Richtung Mölrose kommen. Zwischen Abfahrt Mölrose und Biegen ist die Landstraße in einem Unfall voll gesperrt. Richtung Mölrose bitte die Abfahrt Frankfurt oder West nutzen und über die B87 fahren.
Das war ein Fritz-Kurz-Informat, Gerrit Skatterheimrich.
Samstag, 5.
Dezember.
Die MFS Night im Columbia Fritz. Mit den DJs J-Ray, Robin Garnick, Namito und Marcos Lopez sowie den Live-X, CyberSecrecy und Calculator.
Ey, vor Blipsch noch einmal, kommt jetzt der Chaos Blue Moon?
Wir haben vorhin schon mal hier schon im Vorfeld bedauert, dass wir leider keinen Amiga-Experten jetzt hier unter uns haben. Wir wissen in etwa, wie der Amiga funktioniert. Also er hatte eine serielle Schnittstelle und eine serielle Schnittstelle.
Richtig, naja, siehst du.
Aber sie haben wirklich nur eine einzige gute Sache in ihrem Computer gebaut.
Eine serielle Schnittstelle, naja, das gibt es auch für Amiga.
Eine serielle Schnittstelle.
Ihr hört Chaos Radio, wie man gemerkt hat, an diesem kleinen von einem kreativen Hörer eingesendeten Jingle. Hat der Amiga eigentlich eine serielle Schnittstelle? Weiß nicht.
Hat er dann einen Floppy-Controller oder den hat er zum Teil?
Mit dem können wir zumindest Musik machen.
Aber diesen Titel-Song dann auch noch spielen? Genau, wir fangen jetzt an. Kommen Sie wieder ins Mikro? So, weg mit den Zeitungen. Ihr seid hier an der R. Ich glaube ja.
Ich fang hier an Zeitung zu lesen.
Kryptografie und Privatsphäre.
Die gesetzlich ermächtigten Behörden benötigen eine permanente Überwachung des Fernwöchersverkehrs in Echtzeit. So könnte man das Thema natürlich auch anfangen. Das ist ein Zitat aus dem Entwurf der Europäischen Union, aus der sogenannten Enfopol-Richtlinie, Überwachung des Telekommunikationsverkehrs, Entwurf einer Ratsentschließung in Bezug auf neue Technologien und auch ein bisschen der Grund, warum wir das Thema hier, ich glaube zum zweiten Mal, im Chaosradio, wie sagt man? Behandeln.
Totquatschen.
Kann man auch sagen. Vielleicht kannst du den Text, den du gerade schön zitiert hast, ja auch nochmal ins Deutsche übersetzen. Wir fangen mal anders an. Privatsphäre im Internet. Oder wir räumen es mal so auf. Bin ich denn nicht privat im Internet, sobald ich Internetbenutzer bin?
Nein, das Problem besteht ja daran, dass das Internet im Wesentlichen aus einer gemeinsamen Sprache besteht, die die Computer miteinander sprechen. Und dann gibt es dann noch so einen Adressraum und so ein paar andere Sachen. Und diese Sprache, die erläutern die Universitätsprofessuren immer gern mit den Worten Ja. Also da sind Datenpakete, die haben eine Anschrift, wo sie hingehen, und eine, wie soll man sagen, eine Absenderkennung sozusagen. Und das ist auch fast richtig. Sie haben irgendwie eine Nummer, wo sie hingehen, die kann man beliebig angeben, und sie haben einen Transportteil. Dieser Transportteil allerdings ist kein Datenpaket, weil ein Paket suggeriert, dass da irgendwie erst mal so eine Kiste ist, die transportiert wird, und dann muss man die Kiste aufmachen und dann kann man sich den Inhalt angucken. In Wirklichkeit sind das nicht Datenpostkarten, die da verschickt werden. Den ganzen Tag durch all diese Computer gehen kleine Datenpostkarten, und die kann man eben an vielen Stellen mitlesen, weil es gibt im Internet ja etwas, das heißt dynamisches Routing, und das bedeutet auf gut Deutsch, dass man nicht weiß, wenn man ein Datenpaket zur Reise gibt, über welche Wege ist denn der Empfänger erreicht. Das heißt, man könnte an beliebiger Stelle als Mit-Transporteur oder irgendeinen transportierenden Computer, könnte man angreifen und sagen so, jetzt speicherst du alles mit. Oder noch schlauer, man könnte einfach so einen Computer hinstellen, der als Dienstleistung den Transport anbietet, in Wirklichkeit aber Interesse an den Inhalten hat.
Mit anderen Worten sozusagen ein Abhören von E-Mail-Nachrichten. Dann mal erstmal kurz bei der ganz normalen E-Mail. Damit hat jeder, der einen Internetzugang hat, auf jeden Fall zu tun. Das schickt und bekommt jeder. Lassen wir mal Attachments weg. Erstmal nur ASCII-Zeichen. Die kann ich dann praktisch, oder ich wahrscheinlich nicht, aber mit ein bisschen Aufwand und technischem Wissen kann man die sozusagen abfangen. Merkt das irgendjemand? Merkt das der Absender oder der Empfänger?
Nein. Das ist halt das Schöne an digitaler Kommunikation. Wenn Daten kopiert werden, entstehen dabei keine Spuren. Außer möglicherweise in den Logfiles, aber die sieht man als normaler User nicht. Und es ist tatsächlich so, dass der Verkehr auf dem Internet schon heute ziemlich flächendeckend mitgelauscht wird von den zuständigen Behörden, insbesondere in den USA. Und dass auch viele Internet-Provider in den USA diesen Behörden zugänglich geschaltet haben, damit sie auf diese Daten zugreifen können.
Gibt es dafür Gesetze in den USA, dass das erlaubt ist?
Ich glaube in den USA gibt es so eine generelle Klausel für die NSA, die so ziemlich alles erlaubt, also das Mitlauschen jeglicher elektronischer Kommunikation. Und da das Internet ja ein internationales Netz ist, wird diese Kommunikation halt als grenzüberschreitend definiert. Und in dem Fall dürfen dann halt reinhören.
Das sind ja nun, wenn man da wirklich irgendwie sämtlichen, ich nehme von einem riesen Provider, zum Beispiel von AOL, sage ich, da interessiert mich, da speichere ich irgendwo die ganze E-Mail zwischen. Oder ich sage AOL soll mir einen Zugang verschaffen als Behörde. Ich will da auf jeden Fall Zugriff zu haben, dass ich nachvollziehen kann, welche User welche E-Mails schicken. Das sind halt ziemliche Datenmengen, die da anfallen, oder?
Die lassen sich aber ziemlich problemlos filtern. Also wenn man sich zum Beispiel so was anguckt wie Deja News, da kann man sich irgendwie ziemlich gut angucken, wie solche Datenmengen, die in derselben Größenordnung liegen, nämlich sozusagen die News von den letzten drei Jahren oder wie viele auch immer da drin gespeichert sind, kann man da relativ stressfrei irgendwie durchsuchen. Und man kann sich solche Filter auch so bauen, dass man die halt auch auf Echtzeit E-Mails anwenden kann. Also was passiert ist, dass die Behörden oder auch private Interessenten halt natürlich nach Stichworten suchen in diesem durchgehenden Verkehr und halt sich die Nachrichten, in denen diese Stichworte vorkommen, genauer angucken. Und da ist auch heutige Rechenleistung bei weitem ausreichend für.
Ja, und was dann insbesondere sozusagen die Handhabbarkeit ausmacht, dann könnte das ja von Benutzerseite rangehen mit dem Denken, ja aber ich hab doch A, nicht zu verbergen und B, wären die noch nicht alle meine E-Mails, wo ich denen überhaupt nicht bekannt bin und nicht zu verbergen haben, mitspeichern. Sie tun es eben doch und das hat verschiedene Gründe. Zum einen ist es außerordentlich A, interessant und aufschlussreich und halt völlig unproblematisch von der Datemenge her zunächst einmal zu speichern, wer mit wem kommuniziert. Das gibt ganz schnell Aufschluss, wenn jemand in den Verdacht gerät, was weiß ich, entsprechende links-estonistische Bestrebungen zu haben oder irgendwie irgendwelche Straftaten zu verüben oder sich mit irgendwelchen Leuten anzulegen, die vielleicht gerade an der Macht sind und ihre Macht aber gerne für sich behalten würden oder was auch immer. Zunächst einmal also die Kommunikationszusammenhänge aufzudecken, wer hat mit wem zu tun und dann im nächsten Schritt eben auf die gespeicherten E-Mails zuzugreifen und eben zu gucken, worum es da geht, sodass man eben heute im Internet sehr viel einfacher, sei es legal oder illegal, die Möglichkeit hat, über die Persönlichkeit, über persönliche Beziehungen und so weiter und so fort von Leuten etwas herauszufinden, als würde man diesen Aufwand im sogenannten wirklichen Leben betreiben. Also selbst die Auswertung von Telefongesprächen ist noch aufwendiger. Und wenn man erst an die Kosten einer Überwachungsmaßnahme, einer Observation oder sonst was denkt, da steht alles in überhaupt keinem Verhältnis zu der Einfachkeit, eine Suchmaschine für E-Mails zu bedienen und da einfach mal zu gucken, na was ist denn das für einer. Das ist eben auch für Marketingleute und wenig alles, ja wie soll ich sagen, weniger schlimm, schon interessant.
Man muss aber gar nicht immer erst davon ausgehen, dass man irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, sich mit der Regierung anlegen will, oder dass man irgendwelche Straftaten beschreibt in einer E-Mail oder so, soweit geht es ja gar nicht. Aber es kann prinzipiell sein, es kann auch sein, dass ich mit jemandem kommuniziere, von dem ich gar nicht weiß, dass der irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, was irgendwann mal gemacht hat, plötzlich wird mein Computer mitbeschlagnahmt oder sowas vorstellbar.
Ja, sowas passiert tatsächlich auch und ich denke...
Aber Computerbeschlagnahmen ist ja auch old school. Das ist ja heute nicht mehr notwendig. Wozu willst du einen Computerbeschlagnahmen, wenn du eh weißt, was drin ist?
Ja, also ich denke der wesentliche Punkt dabei ist, dass die Behörden sich da zielstrebig Machtinstrumente aufbauen, wo das Einzige, was einen noch dafür schützt, von diesen Machtinstrumenten betroffen zu werden, die derzeitige Definition von strafbar ist. Das heißt, sobald jemand tatsächlich hingeht und sagt, irgendwie Brillentragen ist strafbar und diese Instrumente gegen Brillenträger angewendet werden, dann werden wir uns alle sehr, sehr wundern. Also es ist so, dass man heutzutage wirklich die Behauptungen aufstellen kann, heute würde ihnen kein Jude mehr entkommen, wenn es soweit kommt.
Zumal es ja so ist, dass die Gesetzgebung derzeit so unglaublich kompliziert ist, dass ich, ich glaube, niemanden kenne, der sich immer an alle Regeln hält. Also jeder hat schon mal falsch geparkt, jeder ist schon mal schwarz gefahren und das geht ja weiter und weiter. Keiner kennt die Steuergesetze genau genug, um sich sicher zu sein, dass er nicht gegen irgendwelche Steuergesetze verstoßen hat. Wie das mit der Drogengesetzgebung ist, wissen wir auch. Es gibt vier Millionen Kiffer, die kriminalisiert werden. Also letzten Endes kann man mit diesen Methoden jeder unbeliebten Person Dreck anhängen und kann diese Personen isolieren. Auch wenn man vielleicht momentan den Leuten, die an der Macht sind, noch guten Willen unterstellt, ist ja nicht gesagt, dass die, die nächstes Jahr kommen, auch noch diesen guten Willen haben. Wenn dann erst mal die Instrumente da sind, dann wird auch jemand sich diese Instrumente bedienen.
Ich erinnere in diesem Zusammenhang immer ganz gerne an die Volkszählung, wo man sich wirklich gedacht hat, was soll das? Der gläserne Bürger, wo ja auch von mir aus auch durchaus teilweise positive Ziele verfolgt wurden, aber insgesamt haben die negativen Auswirkungen davon einfach überwiegt. Und deswegen hat man gesagt, dass man entweder balkottiert oder man sucht andere Wege da nicht mitzumachen. Da haben sich eine Menge Leute gegen gewährt. Und zwar nicht nur Leute, die sich da sowieso immer im Kopf drum machen, sondern auch durch die Presse ist das viel gegangen. Und heute mit einem Internet-Account gebe ich im Grunde genommen viel mehr Preis von mir, was ich mache, wie ich einkaufe, wie ich lebe, was mich für Sachen interessiert, als ich das in der Volkszählung jemals hätte angeben müssen.
Das ist ja nicht nur dein Internet gekauft. Da geht es ja noch weiter mit deinem Mobiltelefon, mit deinem normalen Telefon, mit deiner Post. All diese Dinge. Also es ist so, dass mittlerweile die Digitalisierung des Alltags mittlerweile doch irgendwie die zweite Seite des Riesanowskopfes zeigt. Nicht nur die Grinsende. Also was wir mittlerweile sehen, ist, dass einfach durch die Menge der Daten, die erhoben werden, über den einzelnen Möglichkeiten entstehen für Behörden oder auch böswillige Firmen oder was auch immer, auf das Leben des Einzelnen so massivenweise Einfluss zu nehmen, dass irgendwie die Methoden der Staatssicherheit in der ehemaligen DDR durchaus vergleichbar waren.
Also man merkt es auch schon viel simpler. Man braucht gar nicht erst E-Mail abhören. Also es reicht schon, wenn du in Newsgroups postest, dann wirst du mit Werbemails zugeschüttet. Einfach weil irgendwann mal jemand beschlossen hat.
Ich hab da gerade einen schönen Fall. Da hat jemand in unserer Organisations-Newsgroup die org.ccc aus Spaß irgendwie gepostet. Ja Leute, ich hab hier noch ein paar frisch gedruckte Geldscheine. Die würde ich gerne irgendwie mal waschen. Wer könnte mir denn dabei helfen? Das Ergebnis war, dass zwei Tage später die Bullen bei ihm eingeritten sind und eine Hausdurchsuchung gemacht haben. Fakt, dass er halt irgendwie den Brief...
Hat das zwei Tage gedauert?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das zwei Tage gedauert ist.
Er hat am Freitag Abend gepostet und vom Montag hatten die keinen Bock, oder?
Nee, nee, nee, es war so, dass sie abends gepostet haben und morgens um acht standen sie vor der Tür. Also es ging schon schneller. Er hatte natürlich keine Millionen frisch gedruckten Scheine.
Es war halt wirklich nur ein Witz, aber irgendwie, sie lesen halt alles mit und sie nehmen es ernst da, irgendwie als man es selber ernst nimmt. Und von daher, auch dieser Mann hatte nichts zu verbergen, aber er hat jetzt das Problem, dass irgendwie seine Wohnung halt komplett auf den Kopf gestellt ist. Und was ja geiler, was sie dabei wiederum gefunden haben und sich da Gedanken machen und so weiter. Also das ist, jeder hat was zu verbergen und jeder hat ein potenzielles Problem mit den Entwicklungen, wie sie gerade sind.
Ein schönes Stichwort ist ja auch gerade noch gefallen, weil als wir überlegt haben, wie wir jetzt genau weiter reden mit welchem Thema, ISDN ist natürlich auch so ein schönes Beispiel der schönen, modernen, neuen, digitalisierten Welt. Denn wahrscheinlich kennen das wahrscheinlich viele von euch inzwischen, wenn jemand bei euch anruft oder auch unter Handys natürlich auch digital. Wenn man dann die Nummer des Teilnehmers hat, der anruft oder sogar den Namen, wenn das in dem lokalen Telefonbuch gespeichert ist. Sowas muss man alles explizit abschalten und auch dann ist es nicht wirklich abgeschaltet für...
Also das Einzige, was du abschaltest, ist ja sozusagen die Anzeige der übermittelten Rufnummer. Und es gibt ein Feature, das heißt im Telekom Deutsch arnigen, das heißt anzeigende Rufnummer unterdrücken. Nein, nicht anzeigen, ignorieren, Entschuldigung, arnigen, genau. Nicht anzeigen, ignorieren, das heißt normalerweise übermittelst du deine Rufnummer auch mit, wenn sie nicht angezeigt wird, aber du übermittelst mit, dass sie bitte nicht angezeigt werden soll. Dann gibt es aber Leute, die sind nicht so höflich und respektieren was, sondern die lassen sich die trotzdem anzeigen.
Das ist das sogenannte Polizei-Bit.
Genau, so nennt man das auch. Also insofern kannst du das dir abschmecken. Wir hatten ja eigentlich darüber liegt, ob wir jetzt nicht Hörer anrufen lassen, die uns vielleicht mal oder die vielleicht mal zu ihrem Gefühl was sagen können, ob sie denn was zu verbergen haben oder nicht. Das ist ja immer noch so ein bisschen diese leitliche Diskussion aus Volkszählungstagen, die immer mal wieder aufkommt. Und dann hatten wir überlegt, ob Hörer auch anonyme anrufen können, aber das ist irgendwie anonyme mit ISDN. Das sind zurzeit Begriffe, die kommen irgendwie schwer in einen zentralen Satz bringen.
Wir haben hier kein Display an den Leitungen. Insofern, ihr könnt ja anrufen, ihr könnt von mir aus...
Also vielleicht haben wir...
Wir können ja sagen, dass alle Anrufer...
Man sollte nicht das Gefühl stehen lassen, dass jetzt nur Leute mit ISDN betroffen sind, weil alle mittlerweile am gleichen digitalen Telefon hängen. Jetzt spielt es überhaupt gar keine Rolle, ob man nun ein analoges oder digitales Telefon hat. Also diese ISDN-Technologie ist im Netz bereits überall installiert. Das Netz ist komplett digital. Und ob man nun zu Hause noch ein digitales Telefon hat oder nicht, also wenn man analoges hat, dann hat man überhaupt gar keine Möglichkeit, mehr Einfluss zu dem, was übertragen wird. Und bei ISDN noch so ein bisschen.
Wir können uns ja dann wegen eurer Privatsphäre darauf einigen, dass alle Anrufer, egal ob männlich oder weiblich, egal welchen Alters und egal von wo ihr anruft, heißen heute Fnod zum Beispiel. Insofern könnt ihr unsere Nummer wählen.
Die Fris-Hotline ist geschaltet. 0331 für Potsdam.
7097110.
Und was uns besonders interessiert, ist die Frage, ob ihr meint, dass ihr eine Privatsphäre in dieser digitalen Welt überhaupt braucht. Es gibt ja auch Leute, die haben damals bei der Volkszählung gesagt, das ist der Quatsch, was soll das? Die wissen ja sowieso, wo ich wohne und die können von mir aus alles über mich wissen. Denn ich habe ja nichts zu verbergen. Also wenn ihr der Meinung seid, dass das alles kompletter Quatsch ist, was wir hier reden, dann könnt ihr hier auch anrufen. Und wenn euch zum Beispiel, obwohl ihr überhaupt nicht kriminell seid, ein paar Sachen einfallen, wo ihr sagt, nö, das würde ich schon gerne für mich behalten, dann würden wir auch davon gerne ein bisschen was hören. Hi, hier ist Chaosradio. Stefan.
Aus Berlin.
Schön. Stefan, benutzt du das Internet?
Ich benutze das Internet und ein Handy von jeder Art und Weise.
Alles mögliche. Und machst du dir da Sorgen um deine Privatsphäre?
Ja, weil ich hab mal schon Bedrohungen gekriegt übers Handy, weil jemand mein Nummer rausgekriegt hat.
Was ist da passiert?
Ja, man hat mein Nummer rausgekriegt und ein Typ hat mich erpresst. Wollte 12-mal Pause machen von mir haben. Ich wäre angeblich in Portugal gewesen, mal dieses Jahr, wo ich noch nie in Portugal gewesen bin.
Was ist das denn für eine Geschichte? Da hat irgendjemand sich ständig auf deinem Handy genervt.
Ja, hat mich genervt, aber es war eine Fangschaltung drin, Anzeige und dann hat er Ruhe gelassen.
Hat er dich verwechselt oder war das...
Hat mich verwechselt, hat mich angespornet, hat mich beobachtet oder ich denk mal, ich weiß nicht, keine Ahnung.
Hm, klingt wild.
Klingt sehr wild, ja. Unternimmst du denn jetzt irgendwas, also sagst du gut, dann gibt es eben kein Handy mehr oder so oder ich versuche analog zu leben oder...
Nein, ich wäre mich in jeder Art und Weise rechtlich.
Warum ist man denn eigentlich erpressbar, wenn man in Portugal war?
Ich war nie in Portugal gewesen.
Die Geschichte dahinter können wir natürlich jetzt nicht. Gut, danke erst mal.
Ja, bitteschön.
Mit wem hab ich gesprochen eigentlich?
Ihr wart ein Moderator jetzt gewesen?
Ja, mit allen. Wir hören dich alle.
Ihr hört mich alle.
Ja, wir hören dich alle.
Habt ihr schon unter Decknamen einmal bei euch gemeldet? Naja, ist problematisch mittlerweile geworden.
Mit dem Decknamen.
Ist Stefan jetzt der Deckname?
Frank ist der Deckname. Stefan bin ich real.
Alles klar.
Naja, ist ein cleverer Deckname.
Frank gleich.
Nein, nein, das war nur mein Deckname. Ein richtiger Name und Adresse ist es.
Es ist auch noch nicht ganz klar, ob das Besuchen von Fernländern schon auf der Liste der Straftaten steht.
Nein, ich glaube, da war schon noch eine Geschichte hinter.
Das ist wie so eine Regelung, aber...
Naja, mit dem falschen Mietwagen schon.
Naja, du hattest ja gerade diese Liste, wo stand die sieben terroristischen Länder. Wie war das? Irak, Kuba und...
Sekunde, das habe ich hier ein bisschen weiter oben.
Ich tue davon immer weiter hier in der Zwischenzeit. Hi, hier ist Chaosradio, wer ist denn da?
Eieieiei, die ganz Mutigen.
Damit bleibt man extrem anonym. Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio, wer ist denn da?
Ja, also ich wollte zuerst gerne sagen, erstmal die Pappnase eben da, irgendwie leidet der wahrscheinlich unter Verfolgungswahn oder so. Weil, weiß ich nicht, wegen Portugal und so.
Ja, nur weil man nicht Paranoides heißt, nee, nur weil man Paranoides heißt es nicht, dass sie nicht hinter dir her sind.
Naja, aber wieso ruft ihr denn bei Fritz unterm Decknamen an?
Hat er ja gar nicht, das war ja sein Realname. Wie heißt er denn?
Naja, aber davor hat er ja unter Frank angerufen.
Na lass uns mal über dich reden jetzt.
Genau.
Ja, weiß ich nicht, also ich finde, ihr ist dann eigentlich recht vorteilhaft, muss ich sagen. Also wir haben es jetzt gekriegt und dadurch habe ich mein eigenes Telefon zu Hause gekriegt und die eigene Nummer. Ja und dadurch können eigentlich Kumpels auch nachts und so anrufen.
Also es ist eigentlich, zeig mal.
Naja, das wäre ja mit meinem analogen Telefon auch gegangen und welche gesellschaftliche Auswirkungen das jetzt hat, dass du ein Telefon hast, das ist mir noch nicht ganz klar.
Ja, aber wenn die hier nachts anrufen auf unseren alten Telefon, eben diese alte Nummer, dann wären ja meine Eltern mit wach.
Naja, aber wenn du dir ein analoges Telefon ausgesucht hättest, das...
Also vielleicht sollten wir auch da kurz ein Wort um dieses Missverständnis aus dem Weg zu rein zu sagen. Also wir haben ja nichts gegen Kommunikationstechnologie. Wir nutzen die selbst intensivst. Aber wir möchten ja in der Sendung ein klein bisschen darüber reden, was diese Technologie abgesehen von dem großen Nutzen noch mit sich bringt. Und das ist halt im ISDN das klitzekleine Problem, dass jede Verbindung immer und überall mitgespeichert wird. Und sich auch im Nachhinein bei deinem Telefonanschuss, obwohl das eigentlich erstmal nicht gespeichert wird, beispielsweise nachvollziehen lässt, wer denn da alles angerufen hat. Es gibt da eine Datenbank, die Tera-Datenbank bei der Telekom. Frank, vielleicht noch ein, zwei...
Man kann auch, bevor du loslegst, Frank, es gibt ja auch noch ganz andere Sachen, die man sich dabei überlegen kann. Die klingen ja auch erstmal harmlos. Aber du rufst zum Beispiel irgendwo an, weiß ich nicht, du hast irgendwas gekauft und hast Schwierigkeiten mit dem Produkt und da gibt es eine Support-Hotline. Da rufst du an und deine Nummer ist sofort gespeichert, von der du anrufst. Obwohl deine Frage vielleicht innerhalb von zwei Minuten, was seltenheitswert hätte, nehmen wir mal an, die ist in Kürze geklärt, deine Frage. Damit hat es sich so. Und in Zukunft bekommst du von allen möglichen Firmen, die mit diesem Produkt irgendwas zu tun haben oder ähnliche Sachen herstellen, wirst mit Werbung zugeschüttet. Weil man nämlich deine Nummer gespeichert hat oder du kriegst Anrufe von irgendwelchen Vertretern und so weiter und so fort. All das passiert und wird sich ja auch noch mehr passieren. Sonst stört dich nicht.
Also glaube ich kaum, dass irgendjener so was machen wird, oder?
Ich meine, es ist ja zum Beispiel auch so, wenn du eine eigene Nummer hast, hat die Polizei natürlich den großen Vorteil, wenn du irgendwas Illegales machst, was dir nicht versehentlich noch den Anschluss deiner Eltern mit abhören müssen. Ich meine, es ist so, mit der Einführung des wahrscheinlich digitalisierten Ortslasses in Deutschland hat die Telekom diese Terra-Datenbank eingerichtet. Das ist eine richtig große Datenbank, in der alle, wirklich alle Verbindungsdaten, die im Festnetz anfallen, gespeichert werden. Also wenn du den Hörer abnimmst und irgendeine Nummer wählst, wird gespeichert, dass du diesen Hörer abgenommen hast, wann es war und so weiter und so fort. Und diese Daten stehen selbstverständlich auch den Strafverfolgungsbehörden zur Verfügung. Und diese Daten können auch rückwärts ausgewertet werden. Das heißt also, die Polizei kann zur Telekom gehen und sagen, wir hätten jetzt gerne mal alle Leute, die diesen Anschluss angerufen haben. Also die Daten sind sozusagen auch rückwärts wieder abrufbar.
Was zum Beispiel bei Beratungsstellen für bestimmte Angelegenheiten auch nicht besonders super ist.
Oder klassische Rasterfahndungsbeispiele. Da musst du noch nicht mal was getan haben. Du telefonierst relativ häufig mit zwei oder drei von deinen Freunden, was du aber noch nie wusstest, ist, dass diese Freunde halt irgendwie massiv Autos durch die Gegend schieben oder Frauen oder was gerade hipp ist und viel Geld bringt. So und nun werten sie also diese Terra-Datenbank aus mit ihren Analysetools. Da gibt es auch eine sehr interessante Software, die man einfach so auf diese Datenbank draufstülpt. Und dann kommt da so eine fertige Grafik mit wer mit wem telefoniert und wann raus. So und da ergibt sich sozusagen dann das Bild, dass die drei natürlich untereinander viel telefonieren, aber eben auch mit dir. Also dass es sozusagen nicht drei sind, sondern vier. Und damit wirst du automatisch verdächtig. Und das sind eben alles solche Punkte, wo man unserer Auffassung nach sehr wohl zweimal drüber nachdenken sollte, ob das nicht vielleicht eine Gefährdung für einen darstellt.
Und werden jetzt direkt Gespräche auch gespeichert oder?
Nein. Also es gibt da noch so eine Sache, die haben wir noch gar nicht erwähnt. Also es gibt da zum einen dieses weltweite Telekommunikationsabhörsystem. Das betrifft in Bezug auf den Fernmelderverkehr der Bundesrepublik Deutschland zunächst einmal die Auslandsgespräche. Also die Auslandsgespräche werden definitiv alle gespeichert und durchlaufen diese Echelon-Datenbank, werden also auch nach sensitiven Stichwörtern durchsucht und aber auch abgelagert für den Fall, dass sie hinterher auf die Idee kommen, dass sie einmal herausfinden können, mit wem du zu tun hast oder wer dann über die und die Team geredet hat. Und dann gibt es noch ein etwas unerforschteres technisches System, das fingiert unter dem Namen Wundestelle für Fernmeldestatistik. Was die machen, das weiß eigentlich keiner so genau. Das ist eine Außenstelle des Bundesnachrichtendienstes. Und nicht zu sagen der Bundesnachrichtendienst selbst. Die haben ein Netz von etwa 130, 180, im Bereich von 150 Stationen in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland. Und zwar so sternförmig angelegt, das heißt in den größeren Städten. Und dann jeweils in den Außenbezirken nochmal irgendwelche Dinge. Und was die genau machen, das kann ich jetzt nicht mit Gewissheit sagen, aber es gibt sehr wohl Leute, die behaupten, dass die auch den inländischen Fernmeldeverkehr in bestimmten Regionen bzw. bei der Beobachtung bestimmter Zusammenhänge einfach mal überwachen und mit protokollieren.
Also können die jetzt auch direkt, bis ich mir am Telefon zum Beispiel mal das Wort Haschisch fällt oder so. Das können die dann direkt, also sehen sie denn auf ihrer Liste, der und der Anrufer hat eben dann und dann Haschisch gesagt.
Ganz genau.
Das ist ganz schön krass.
Das ist ganz schön krass, ja.
Ich sag schon mal Tschüss zu dir, weil hier sind jetzt ganz viele Anrufer, ja. Da werden wir sicher noch ein paar Fragen jetzt haben zu dem Thema. Dir auch.
Danke.
Tschüss.
Übrigens, zwischendurch, ich hab die Liste der Seven Countries gefunden. Also es ist so die, aber das eigentlich, vielleicht greift das jetzt vor, ne?
Ja, lass erst noch ein bisschen telefonieren. Ich fand den Satz gerade ganz interessant, sowas macht doch keiner oder sowas machen die doch nicht. Also dazu muss man einfach nur mal so mit ganz klassischer, da brauchen wir kein Telefon, nichts, sondern geht es einfach nur um Adressen. Adressenlisten werden in der Werbebranche, in der Direct-Marketing-Branche, wie man das ja nennt, irgendwie zu wirklich immensen Summen gehandelt. Und dann braucht man nur mal, wenn man irgendwie einem Gewinnspiel, die sind ja zu nichts anderem da, als zur Adressen-Generierung, zur Adresslisten-Generierung, wenn man da irgendwo mal dran teilnimmt, braucht man nur mal seinen Namen falsch schreiben, und dann kann man warten, was in den nächsten Wochen alles mit dieser falschen Schreibweise an Werbung ins Haus geflattert kommt. Und da sieht man das in ganz klassischen Beispielen, und so wird das natürlich auf alle elektronischen Medien super ausweitbar sein. Und ich muss sagen, mich nervt das einfach extrem. Mich nervt das extrem, wenn meine Mailbox zum Beispiel im Computer voll ist mit irgendwelchen Mailing-Listen, in die ich mich nie eingetragen hab. Ja, und es ist anstrengend da rauszufiltern, ob da vielleicht noch was ist.
Ein schöner Sport für den Nachmittag ist, wenn man mal umgezogen ist und man muss sozusagen sowieso alle Firmen, bei denen man ein Abo hat, oder die aus irgendwelchen sonstigen Gründen die Adresse wissen müssen, dass man denen also die neue Adresse gibt, dann sollte man einfach auch, wenn man in der 15 wohnt, nicht 15 schreiben, sondern mal schön durchnummerieren. 15 A, 15 B, 15 C, 15 D. Das kommt in der Regel alles noch an. Aber dann sieht man halt, wenn man sozusagen 15 D mal von mehr als einem bekommt, welchen Weg diese Adressen nehmen. Also das ist schon mal ein schöner Tipp.
Da hat schon jemand aufgelegt, aus der Paranoia ist es auch. Siehst du alle jetzt, oh, wenn ich da jetzt beim Chaosradio anrufe...
Das hilft übrigens nichts aufzulegen, auch nicht zu stimmen. Die kommenden Gespräche werden gespeichert.
Und zwar zum Gespräch von vorhin hätte ich gerne nochmal eine Frage. Und zwar, die Gesprächsdaten bei der Telekom werden gespeichert. Wie ist es denn mit den anderen Telefonanbietern, wo man sich einhält mit 010 sowieso?
Ja Moment, das was ich da eben gesagt habe, war ja nicht, die Gesprächsdaten werden bei der Telekom gespeichert. Ja ja, nee Moment, das war ein bisschen missverständlich formuliert, weil wir reden immer noch gerne vom Telefonnetz. Das Telefonnetz besteht ja aus mir als einem Anbieter. Und die Bundesstelle für Fernmelde Statistik, die ist auch sicherlich nicht nur an den Leitungswegen der Telekom orientiert, sondern auch an den der Fremdanbieter.
Also die Telekom vermittelt ja den größten Teil der Gespräche der Fremdanbieter. Und wenn du nicht gerade von einem Netz eines Fremdanbieters in das Netz eines Fremdanbieters, also des selben Fremdanbieters telefonierst, das geht, dieses Gespräch hat irgendeiner Stelle Überleitung der Telekom und wird auch in der Teradatenbank erfasst, weil die Telekom natürlich auch ihre internen Abrechnungen gegenüber den Drittanbietern machen muss. Selbstverständlich sind auch die anderen Anbieter verpflichtet, in genau demselben Umfang diese Verbindungsdaten den Sicherheitsbehörden zur Verfügung zu stellen. Also es hilft dir auch nichts, wenn du irgendwie deinen Anschluss auf Aquapreselection oder was immer stellst. Die Daten werden selbstverständlich da auch gespeichert.
Wenn es nicht gerade so läuft, wie kann es denn sonst laufen?
Na was heißt, wie kann es sonst laufen? Es ist halt so, dass die Polizei in der Bundesrepublik, hat ja auch die Geheimdienste vor allen Dingen, haben ja doch schon eine relativ solide Datenbedarfsregelung. Und da ist es halt so, dass die sagen, wenn du Telekommunikation anbieten willst, wie auch immer, musst du unsere Forderungen nach Datenspeicherung akzeptieren. Und die Problematik ist, man könnte selbstverständlich ein Telefonnetz so aufbauen, dass diese Daten nicht anfallen. Das ist ganz klar möglich. Zum Beispiel gibt es in Dresden, Leipzig von Herrn Fitzmann gibt es ein paar ganz gute Konzepte zu diesem Thema. Bloß es wurde mit Absicht tatsächlich der technische Weg gewählt, bei dem halt die meisten Daten anfallen über diese Verbindungen.
Es gibt zum Beispiel diesen Telefonanbieter First Telekom, wo man sich also mit einer 0800er Nummer einwählt und dann bekommt man also eine Ansage, wie viel man auf dem Konto hat und dann kommt ein neues Preizeichen und das geht doch sicher über einen anderen Weg, ne?
Naja, wenn du Glück hast, dann geht es sogar über eine ausländische Leitung. Das heißt, dass du den BND sicher drinnen hast.
Wenn ich Glück habe, ja.
Also Callback zum Beispiel sind halt immer ausländische Leitungen. Ausländische Gespräche werden halt flächendeckend nach Stichworten durchsucht. Das heißt, also da schließt du dann auch deine innerdeutschen Gespräche sozusagen ausländisch über die BND-Datenbank. Ich glaube, die hatten auch ein kleines Ressourcenproblem, nachdem Callback irgendwie aufkam.
Aber ich denke, wir können ja bei der Gelegenheit, weil die Fragen jetzt auch so ein bisschen in die Richtung gehen, noch mal ganz kurz über das Thema. Wir hatten ja irgendwie Kryptographie, wenn ich es recht im Sinne als Thema in dieser Sendung auch, und nicht nur Privatsphäre. Und Kryptographie wäre eben genau das Werkzeug, mit dem man, obwohl die Leitung überwacht und obwohl das alles gespeichert wird, sozusagen sich dagegen schützen kann, dass es ausgewertet wird, indem man die...
Dass die Inhalte ausgewertet werden.
Dass die Inhalte ausgewertet werden und, gut, ja, ist schon richtig. Dann noch zu versteuern, wer mit wem redet, ist deutlich komplexer.
Wie man das machen kann, werden wir natürlich im Laufe dieser Sendung erläutern. Ich hab noch eine Frage an Manne, bevor ich mich verabschiede, weil ich gehe jetzt einfach mal davon aus, dass du nicht deshalb fragst und dich nicht deswegen für das Thema interessierst, weil du planst morgen eine Bank zu überfallen. Aber warum interessiert es dich? Also wie wichtig ist dir da deine Privatsphäre und warum?
Ja, für mich persönlich ist es weniger wichtig. Also es hat mich jetzt in dem Zusammenhang interessiert, weil Daten gespeichert werden über sämtliche Gespräche und dann muss ich mal die Unterschiede wissen. Also es sind Anbieter und ob es da Unterschiede gibt. Also ich hab keine Befürchtungen persönlich.
Bist du denn jemand der, weiß nicht, im Bereich Telefonen können wir gleich mal drüber reden, aber sagen wir mal bei E-Mail. Da gibt es ja Schiffrierungsprogramme, da kann man also Kryptographie anwenden. Telefonen sehe ich ja auch irgendwie, aber da könnt ihr gleich noch was zu sagen. Würdest du Gespräche oder elektronische Post denn verschlüsseln, um einfach dabei zu sein und es auch zu machen? Obwohl du selber sagst, für mich persönlich interessiert es eigentlich nicht so. Für mich persönlich ist es nicht so interessant.
Ich würde es verschlüsseln, wenn ich irgendwie nicht möchte, dass das so einfach mitgelesen würde. Aber das ist wahrscheinlich selten. Wie ist das eigentlich, wenn man bei E-Mails als Anhang eine Wave-Datei, also praktisch eine Sprachdatei, nachher anfügt, kann die genauso gut abgehört werden?
Sicher.
Wenn man sie jetzt zum Beispiel verschlüsselt, also komprimiert und verschlüsselt.
Also wenn du sie verschlüsselst, dann ist sie verschlüsselt?
Verschlüsselung bedeutet aber, dass du tatsächlich richtige Verschlüsselungsprogramme, wie zum Beispiel PGP, verwendest. Und nicht nur zum Beispiel die Verschlüsselung, in Anführungsstrichen, die ja zum Beispiel bei SIP dabei ist. Dabei handelt es sich im Wesentlichen nur um eine Verschleierung, wo auch irgendwie Cracking-Tools dafür sind im Internet wirklich ziemlich verbreitet. Also wenn du tatsächlich Dinge wirklich verbergen willst, und das sollte man möglichst weit im Umfang tun, um den Jungs irgendwie das Leben nicht allzu leicht zu machen, dann sollte man auch richtige Verschlüsselungsprogramme benutzen. Mittlerweile sind die so komfortabel, dass man doch nicht mehr vor Zurückschrecken muss.
Also auf diesen Wege könnte ich zum Beispiel irgendwelche Sprachinformationen oder so was per E-Mail schicken, ohne dass das also dann...
Manuel, ich sag dir schon mal Tschüss.
Danke auch, ciao.
Ich würde sagen, einen Anrufer nehmen wir noch zum Thema und dann erklären wir ein bisschen, wie man da mit Kryptographie dann zwischengehen kann. Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio. Wer ist denn da? Jo, wer bist du denn? Hallo Robert.
Na, ich würde gerne was sagen zu den Verschlüsseln. Was die Telekom da für ein Mist macht, das kann jeder da wenig Ahnung haben vom Internet und vom Entschlüsseln, das kann doch nicht knacken. Es ist sinnlos, was sie da haben.
Wovon redest du konkret?
Also hier zum Beispiel von Datenschutz. Also von einigen Kunden so gelesen hab und so. Ich will das jetzt mal, falls jemand von der Telekom vielleicht mitfährt, dass die mal sagen, dass sie uns drum kümmern sollen.
Naja, aber worüber wir hier reden, sind ja eher Sachen, die gar nicht in erster Linie die Telekom zu verantworten hat, sondern die so gesehen alle zu verantworten haben, weil sie sich alle daran beteiligen, beziehungsweise die der Gesetzgeber zu verantworten hat, weil er eben nicht nur das Abhören von Verbindungen mit richterlichen Beschluss zulässt, sondern auch in dem Moment, und da gibt es eben einen riesigen Ausnahmekatalog, wenn die Bedarfsträger auf die Idee kommen, dass sie irgendwie Lust drauf haben, dich abzuhören, um nicht zu sagen, wenn sie den Verdacht hegen, du hättest Bestrebungen gegen die freiheitlich-demokratische Grundordnung. Insofern reden wir hier nicht nur von technischen Problemen und technischen Lösungen, und da reichen sich die Unternehmen in der Regel gegenseitig das Wasser, sondern eben auch von den Grundlagen, die es außerhalb von Technik gibt.
Robert, dank dir erstmal, ja? Wie sieht denn das überhaupt aus? Vorhin hat jemand von euch gesagt, dass die, das als Kommunikationsanbieter, also bleiben wir mal im Telefonbereich kurz, gehst du praktisch die Verpflichtung ein, dann auch gegenüber dem Gesetzgeber dich natürlich an bestimmte Sachen zu halten, also bestimmte Daten zugänglich zu machen. Wie sieht da im Moment die Gesetzgebung aus im Internetbereich als Provider? Also muss ich zum Beispiel, wenn ich Internetdienstleistungen anbiete als Provider, muss ich dann dafür sorgen, dass die Krypto zum Beispiel Zugang zu den im letzten Monat angefallenen E-Mails über meinen Server hat oder so?
Also abgesehen davon, dass ich da mal so bin, dass wir jetzt an welchem Mal wieder Musik spielen sollten, ist die Sache die...
Das ist eine tolle Antwort auf meine Frage.
Ich hab da nur den Satz angefangen mit abgesehen davon und da geht weiter mit, ist die Sachlage im Moment die, dass also derjenige, der Telekommunikationsdienstleistungen für andere geschäftsmäßig erbringt, so lautet dieses Gesetz, also verpflichtet ist, die im Telekommunikationsgesetz dafür skizzierten Anforderungen zu erfüllen. Früher war das ja so, es gab nur einen Anbieter, die Post sozusagen, dann wurde die Telekommunikation, wie man sagt, dereguliert. Das heißt, es bekam auch andere Marktteilnehmer die Möglichkeit, also Dienste dort anzubieten und auch Internetprovider fallen unter dieses Gesetz. Und was der Staat bei der Gelegenheit gemacht hat, ist eben die Überwachungsbefugnisse und diese ganzen Regelungen gleich mal kräftig auszuweiten. Ein Internetprovider kann auf der Ebene verschiedener Lizenzklassen tätig werden. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo beispielsweise unser Lieblingsprovider SNAFU hier einfach nur die Möglichkeit uns bieten will, irgendwie den anzurufen mit Modem und da irgendwie Internet dann zu haben über eine Standleitung, ist das eine Sache. Dann ist das eine relativ niedrige Lizenzklasse, die die dafür brauchen. In dem Moment, wo man aber beispielsweise einen unvermittelten Anschluss zur Zweidreitleitung haben will, also nehmen wir mal an, ich will zu Hause einen ADSL-Anschluss haben oder irgendwie schnelles Internet aus der Steckdose halt, dann wiederum braucht es nach wie vor eine Anerkennung beim TKG. Und beim TKG heißt das dann, dass sie eben den Bedarfsträgern Leitungen schalten müssen, die, wenn die auf die Idee kommen, mich zu überwachen, eben in Echtzeit alle Datenverbindungen, die von und zu meinem Anschlussgehen eben parallel übertragen müssen und alle solche Sachen, auch die Kundendatei des Providers muss dann der Regulierungsbehörde wiederum, die für die Bedarfsträger die Daten pflegt, abrufbar sein und all solche Sachen. Im Nachhinein allerdings ist es nicht, zumindest noch nicht vorgesehen, dass E-Mails jetzt die Inhaltsdaten übertragen werden, aber was die Nutzung sogenannter Teeledienste betrifft, das ist also so eine Gesetzesdefinition, weil die natürlich, die haben auch noch ein bisschen ein Problem, das Internet zu verstehen. Das ist ja ein offenes Geheimnis. Und also E-Mails fallen darunter im Moment nicht, aber die Nutzung beispielsweise oder die, was weiß ich, wenn du irgendwelche Server anwirst und dir da Dienste beziehst oder bei der Bank machst oder irgendwie sowas, dann ist es durchaus denkbar, dass diese Daten auch im nachhinein von dir übermittelt werden.
Ihr hört Chaos Radio, den monatlichen Computer-Blumuen hier bei Fritz mit dem Chaos Computer Club und mit meiner Wenigkeit namens Johnny am Mikrofon. Es geht heute um Kryptografie, um Privatsphäre. Wir haben schon ein bisschen darüber geredet, auch mit euch telefoniert. Wir werden nachher auch noch weiter tun, aber erst gibt es wieder ein bisschen Infos, nämlich eigentlich jetzt eher langsam mal zum Thema kommen, wenn es dann eine Privatsphäre im Internet und in diversen anderen digitalen Diensten gar nicht erst gibt, was kann man, wie kann man sich dagegen schützen? Und dann sind wir dann nämlich genau bei diesem Thema Kryptographie.
Ja, also Kryptographie, Verschlüsselung, das ist genau das, was man da machen kann. Es gibt diverse Programme, mit denen man dann seine E-Mail-Kommunikation bzw. seine Telefonbesprüche verschlüsseln kann. Und viele von diesen Programmen taugen nichts, weil die Leute, die sie geschrieben haben, sich eingebildet haben, ja, also wir nehmen jetzt den Zufallszahlen-Generator von Borland Pascal und den addieren wir da einfach drauf und schon sieht das anders aus. Und auf die Idee ist jeder schon mal gekommen, dass sich damit beschäftigt hat und man kann das knacken. Also vergesst das ganz schnell wieder. Und auch diese Vielzahl von Programmen, die unter den komischsten Namen erhältlich ist, davon sollte man Abstand nehmen, wenn man da keinen Source Code zu hat. Denn es gibt gute und schlechte Verschlüsselung und sie lässt sich für den Leiden nicht auseinanderhalten. Die einzige Möglichkeit zu sagen, dass Verschlüsselung gut ist, ist, dass es den Source Code gibt, dass die Experten den Source Code gesehen haben und dass da keiner ein Problem gesehen hat. Und zwar nicht nur für einen Monat oder sowas, sondern über Jahre hinweg. Und eins der Programme, auf das das zutrifft, ist PGP. In einigen Versionen gibt es jetzt mittlerweile keinen Source Code mehr. Auch von diesen sollte man Abstand halten, auch wenn sie bequem zu benutzen sind. Bei den anderen ist es so, dass es da bei der Verschlüsselung mehrere Teile gibt. Nämlich braucht man, um etwas zu verschlüsseln, einen Schlüssel, den Key, der sehr kurz ist, den man sich merken kann, den man irgendwo eingeben kann, auf Platte haben kann. Mit diesem Key wird dann das gesamte Fall verschlüsselt. Es gibt von diesem Key jetzt zwei Sorten. Einmal das klassische, ich habe den Key und mein Gesprächspartner hat den Key und ich verschlüssel das damit und er kann das damit entschlüsseln. Sprich, der Schlüssel zum Verschlüsseln und zum Entschlüsseln, der ist gleich. Und dann gibt es sogenannte asymmetrische Verfahren, da ist der Schlüssel zum Verschlüsseln und der Schlüssel zum Entschlüsseln verschieden. Das wiederum bedeutet, dass ich sozusagen den Leuten den Schlüssel zum Verschlüsseln geben kann. Die können das alle fröhlich verschlüsseln und ich bin der Einzige, der den Schlüssel zum Entschlüsseln hat und kann mir das dann damit angucken. Das ermöglicht jetzt also, dass ich einfach losgehe, wir einen solchen sogenannten öffentlichen Schlüssel mache, den an alle meine Freunde verteile und die können wir dann verschlüsselte Mail schicken, die nur ich lesen kann. Ja, das ist auch genau das, was PGP macht. Und ein relativ wichtiger Punkt bei der ganzen Geschichte ist dieses Schlüsselmanagement. Also wenn ich jetzt durch die Welt gehe, meinen öffentlichen Schlüssel verteile und den den Leuten gebe, dann müssen die ja wissen, dass es wirklich mein öffentlicher Schlüssel ist. Und dafür gibt es sogenannte Signaturen unter den Schlüsseln. Das heißt, dass ich zum Beispiel mich mit jemanden persönlich treffe und dem meinen öffentlichen Schlüssel gebe. Und dann schicke ich per Mail oder er bekommt aus einer anderen Quelle den öffentlichen Schlüssel von jemand anders, den ich aber unterschrieben habe. Und jetzt hat er mich persönlich getroffen, also kann er meine Unterschrift überprüfen unter diesem Schlüssel. Und mir glaubt er, dass ich den getroffen habe. Und deswegen weiß er, dass der Schlüssel von demjenigen kommt, von dem er zu kommen scheint. Und damit wird so eine Art Sicherheitsnetzwerk aufgebaut. Das ist auch die komplizierteste Geschichte bei dem ganzen PGP. Also da irgendwie auf Verschlüssel und Endschlüssel zu klicken. Das ist ja mittlerweile ganz einfach. Man holt sich das PGP aus dem Netz, dann klickt man auf install und dann hat man einen Button in seinem Eudora oder welches schreckliche Programm man immer auch verwendet. Und dann klickt man da drauf und dann ist es verschlüsselt. Und dann klickt er auf der anderen Seite wieder drauf und muss seine Passphrase eingeben, dann ist es entschlüsselt. Aber man sollte sich mit diesem Keymanagement mal auseinandersetzen und versuchen zu verstehen, was da vor sich geht.
Also vor allem sollte man überhaupt erst mal anfangen, sich damit zu beschäftigen. Also es stellt sich nach einer Weile einfach heraus, dass dieses so kompliziert klingende Grundprinzip nicht wirklich schwierig zu verstehen ist. Ihr habt Telefonnummern begriffen, ihr habt sogar verstanden, was eine URL ist. Das mit dem Public und dem Private Key, das kriegt ihr auch noch hin.
Ich hab das auch irgendwann verstanden.
Das klingt immer alles so tschechnisch, und es klingt immer alles so schwierig, aber der Weg dahin ist nicht wirklich weit. Zumal, wie André ja schon richtig sagte, die Software für die gängigen Desktopbetriebssysteme mittlerweile auch multiglicky ist, sodass man ohne größere Programmiererkenntnisse leicht in seine Software integrieren kann.
Selbst auf dem Mac, wo es ja oft bei bestimmter Art von Software dann doch ein bisschen dauert, bis endlich da eine vernünftige bedienbare Version rauskommt, am Anfang war PGP wirklich doch noch ein bisschen schwieriger zu benutzen. Da musste man von Hand irgendwie Copy-Paste und so. Inzwischen ist das für die ganzen Mail-Programme, Eudora, bla, was es alles noch gibt, ist das dann einfach ein Menü-Item oder ist sogar dann in dem Mail-Fenster drin. Das heißt, ich schreib eine Mail, klicke auf Verschlüsseln und die wird abgeschickt. Und wenn ich eine Verschlüsselte kriege, klicke ich auf Endschlüsseln, gebe meine Passphrase ein, mein Passwort sozusagen, mein Passwort-Satz und dann geht das alles automatisch.
Naja, sagen wir mal, welche war eigentlich die letzte Version von den bunten Versionen, wo es noch einen Source Code gab?
Ja, ich glaube, das war die 553i.
Das war dort noch die, die aus Büchern abgetippt und noch von den Cipherpunks gegengelesen wurden?
Muss man darüber noch ein paar Sätze verlieren, zum Beispiel über diese Exportgeschichten und so?
Ja, sollte man schon. Also es ist ja so, dass klassischerweise diese Verschlüsselungstechnik insbesondere von der amerikanischen Regierung sozusagen als gefährliches Wirtschaftsgut entsprechenden Regulierungen unterworfen ist. Das heißt, zu Zeiten des Kalten Krieges wurden Verschlüsselungsprodukte, Algorithmen und all solche Sachen als Waffen, als Munition unter entsprechende Regulierungen gestellt. Das hieß, es wurde nur das exportiert oder es durfte nur das exportiert werden, wo eben sichergestellt war, dass die amerikanische Regierung den Schotter mitlesen kann. Mit dem Ende des Kalten Krieges sind ja die amerikanischen Geheimdienste insbesondere neuen Aufgaben überstellt worden. Der Feind sind nicht mehr die bösen Russen und die Aufgabe ist folglich jetzt die Wirtschaftsspionage und ja überhaupt die Durchsetzung des Machtgefuges auf anderen Wegen. Und das heißt, dass die Regulierungen jetzt zwar nicht mehr dem Verteidigungsministerium unterstellt sind, sondern dem Wirtschaftsministerium, aber ansonsten hat sich eigentlich überhaupt nichts geändert. Es darf nach wie vor nur das exportiert werden, wo man eben mitlesen kann, bzw. wo die amerikanische Regierung mitlesen kann. Und dieses Exportverbot konnte oder wurde jetzt eine Zeit lang dadurch umgangen, dass es in Amerika abgesehen von diesem Gesetz noch einen Verfassungsgrundsatz gibt, nämlich der Freedom of Speech. Und nachdem war es also möglich, den Source Code von diesem Programm in Büchern abzudrucken. Und diese Bücher, da konnte der Export nicht verhindert werden, sodass die Bücher also Problemen, was nach Europa geschickt werden konnten, da mussten die Programme dann wieder abgetippt werden. Dann hatte man zwar sozusagen auch den Export von Software gegangen, aber eben unter Umgehung dieser juristischen Feinheiten.
Da gibt es auch noch mal so eine schöne Geschichte, wo sich jemand gefragt hat, was eigentlich ist, wenn er den Source Code sich tätowieren lässt, was dann ist, wenn er ausreißt?
Hat es nicht sogar mal jemand ausprobiert?
Hat stattgefunden, ja, hat stattgefunden, gab aber keine weiteren Probleme.
Das sehen wir schon.
War aber dann wahrscheinlich irgendwie auch so Source Code irgendwie als T-Shirt und so.
Aber gibt das nicht Junkerheits oder so bei Tätowierungen?
Keine Ahnung. Es gibt auch Leute, man kann ja in Perl wunderschöne Sachen machen, man kann auch Verschlüsselungsalgorithmen in Perl in wenigen Zeilen programmieren und dann gibt es jemanden, der hat in seiner Signature zu stehen. Ich bin ein internationaler Waffenhändler und dann darunter die RSA-Implementation in Perl in drei Zeilen. Also dieses Gesetz ist schon ziemlich sinnlos, wenn man sich das mal genauer anguckt.
Ja, aber es dient halt einem bestimmten Zweck. Es dient nicht dem Zweck, das komplett zu verhindern, sondern es dient dem Zweck, die ganze Entwicklung in diesem Bereich zu verlangsamen und insofern ist denen das ja auch tatsächlich gelungen.
Na ja, verlangsamen ist nicht ganz so richtig. Also insbesondere betrifft es ja die Produkte, die eben marktreif von amerikanischen Firmen gemacht werden. Wir haben ja so eine gewisse Dominanz von amerikanischen Softwareanbietern, nicht nur auf der Betriebssystemebene, sondern eben auch auf der Ebene der Benutzerprogramme, Mailprogramme und so weiter und so fort. Und genau diese Produkte werden ja als Massenware in Amerika produziert und hier lediglich rübergeschippt, wie man sagt. Und exakt diese Produkte trifft es zu 100 Prozent. Weil das sind auch Firmen, die sich nicht unbedingt mit so juristischen Feinheiten auseinandersetzen, sondern diesen selbstverständlich bemüht, sich an die Gesetze ihres Landes zu halten, um ordentlich Geld zu verdienen und wenn ihn die Gesetze ihres Landes vorschreiben, eben dabei Sicherheitsprodukte hinter Türen reinzubauen bzw. Mitlesemöglichkeiten zu lassen, dann machen die das immer. Die wollen ja Kohle machen.
Es gibt halt einige Firmen, die sind wenigstens so ehrlich, das dann offen zu dokumentieren, wie es zum Beispiel bei IBM der Fall ist mit der Lotus Notes Verschlüsselung. Da kann man, wenn man da Lust drauf hat, sich die gerne die anschlägigen Redbooks aus dem Internet ziehen. Das ist sehr genau beschrieben, wie es funktioniert. Also wie da effektiv die Key-Linge für die NSA so kurz gemacht wird, dass man sich die Sache on the fly als NSA durchlesen kann.
Naja, wobei, also ich finde, da bist du jetzt ein bisschen zu nett, weil, also öffentlich dokumentiert, war dieses Redbook nicht da unten in dieser...
In der Hinterzeller hinter den Leoparden und so weiter.
Das erinnert mich an eine bestimmte Umgehungsstraße in einem bestimmten Buch. Mehr zu diesem Thema gleich nach dem Fritz-Kurzinfo hier im Chaosradio. 23 Uhr 31.
Richtungsbestimmungen. Spitzenpolitiker von SPD und Bündnisgrün sind am Abend zu ihrer ersten Koalitionsrunde zusammengekommen. Bei dem Gespräch geht es unter anderem um eine bessere Abstimmung ihrer Regierungspolitik. Beide Seiten wollen Streitigkeiten über die Steuerpolitik und die 620 Marktjobs ausräumen. Reaktion. Israel hat am Abend erneut den vereinbarten Truppenabzug aus dem Westjordanland gestoppt. Die Regierung begründete die Entscheidung mit dem Angriff einer palästinensischen Menge auf einen israelischen Soldaten bei Ramallah. Der Truppenabzug werde erst dann fortgesetzt, wenn die Palästinenserführung von der Ausrufung eines eigenen Staates im Mai kommenden Jahres absehe, hieß es. Bahnvorhaben. Die Deutsche Bahn will im nächsten Jahr bis zu 18.000 Arbeitsplätze streichen. Dies bestätigte Konzernchef Ludewig heute nach einer Aufsichtsratssitzung in Berlin. Das Gremium hatte zuvor ein neues Programm für mehr Pünktlichkeit und besseren Service gebildet. Marschroute. Das Bundeskabinett hat heute Ziele der deutschen Europapolitik beraten. Deutschland übernimmt am 1. Januar die Ratspräsidentschaft der Europäischen Union. Hauptvorhaben ist ein Beschäftigungspakt, um die Zahl der zurzeit 18 Millionen Arbeitslosen in den EU-Mitgliedstaaten zu senken. Fahndungserfolg. Die von der NATO geführte SV-Truppe in Bosnien hat den Serben General Krstic festgenommen. Krstic werden Verbrechen gegen die Menschlichkeit im Zusammenhang mit der gefallenen bosnischen Moslem-Enclave Srebrenica vorgeworfen. Fußball im Viertelfinale des DFB-Pokals verlor Zweitligis Tennis-Brosja bei Werder Bremen 1 zu 2 nach Verlängerung. Zweitligis Rot-Weiß-Oberhausen bezwang Bosja München Gladbach 2 zu 0. Der VfL Wolfsburg gewann gegen die Sportfreunde Siegen 3 zu 1. Bereits gestern zog Bayern München ins Halbfinale. Heute Nacht bedeckt etwa Schneegriesel bei minus 6 bis minus 10 Grad. Morgen dann meist Heiton trocken. Temperaturen minus 5 bis minus 1 Grad.
Verkehr.
Keine aktuellen Meldungen mehr. Wir wünschen euch gute Fahrt.
Ein Fritz-Kurz-Info mit Gerald Kötter-Henrich.
Fritz präsentiert AKW, flinke, latente Schlaflosigkeit und den Ohren der Platten auflegt. Faithless, live in Berlin, Montag, 14. Dezember in der Arena.
Wie hätte er das gedacht?
Das sind die Puppe.
Da als Hippie-Time beginnt.
Tims Haare werden wieder länger.
Noch länger?
Das ist der allgemeine Trend zum Retro-Design. Fast uns jetzt alle.
Kurthosen, längere Haare.
Aber wie gesagt, wenn dir das nicht so bewusst war, der Weg von den Hippies zu den Hackern, der ist kein langer Weg.
Dann ein rechtfertige nicht mal, Tim.
Setz dich mal zu, wie ihr da rauskommt.
Na ja, da gab es doch damals diesen Krieg, diesen Vietnamkrieg, wo sich die Hippies kräftig gegen aufgelehnt hat. Und da gab es dann unter anderem auch so eine Gruppe, die nannten sich die Hippies, die es überhaupt nicht eingesehen haben, dass sie, wenn sie telefonieren und dafür Geld zahlen, dass dieses Geld zum Teil dafür verwendet wurde, den Vietnamkrieg zu finanzieren. Da wurde damals extra noch Gebühr draufgeschlagen. Und aus Protest haben sie eben Methoden erfunden, wie man kostenlos telefonieren kann. Das ist im Prinzip die Geburtsstunde des Phone-Freaking gewesen. Und aus dieser Szene heraus, diesen Hippies, entstanden dann halt auch so Hacker-Uhr-Magazine wie die TAP, wo dann wiederum irgendwann die 2600 hervorgegangen ist, die dann letzten Endes auch ausschlaggebend war für die Gründung der Datenschleuder. Also das hat alles Bezug zueinander.
Es gibt aber noch einen direkten Bezug zu diesem Song. Übrigens im Chat kam gerade der Kommentar, dass der Sänger sich hier anhörte zu paar Zahnschmerzen, aber das ist nur warme Hand. Dieser Song hat aber eine ganz besondere Bedeutung.
Ja, der Titelsong ist so ein Kinofilm, der Mitte Januar in die Kinos kommt. Der Film heißt 23 und befasst sich mit dem Leben von Karl Koch. Karl Koch ist ein Hacker, der vor 10 Jahren sehr in den Medien stand, bekannt geworden durch einen KGB-Hack, Spionage-Verwicklung, der dann, oh Wunder, oh Wunder, tot im Wald gefunden wurde. Die Vergangenheit holt uns da regelmäßig wieder ein, wie es den Anschein hat. Und die Geschichte von Karl Koch wird halt in diesem Film erzählt. Das ist kein Dokumentarfilm, sondern es ist wirklich ein Spielfilm, aber er versucht schon sehr nah an der damaligen Geschichte zu bleiben, auch wenn er sich selber nicht als Dokumentarfilm versteht. Aber die Aufarbeitung dieses Themas ist mit vielen Feingefügeln gemacht worden. Und von daher haben wir uns auch entschlossen, den Film auf dem Chaos Communication Kongress im Dezember zu zeigen. Also er wird dort zwei Wochen vor dem offiziellen Kinostart zu sehen sein.
Mehr Info unter www.23.de Unter Annahmen.
Und natürlich www.CCCDE.
Ähm, damit gehen wir zurück wieder zum Thema Kryptographie. Es kam jetzt im Studio-Chat, also hier im www.chat auf den Fritz-Seiten, wurde heftig diskutiert, es gibt ja außer PGP auch noch andere Verschlüsselungsmethoden usw. Die Frage kam immer wieder auf, welche ist denn die vermutlich sicherste? Und dann kam auch die Frage nach etwas, wo ich noch nie was gehört hab, nämlich Gnu-PG.
Ja, Gnu-PG, dazu kann ich was sagen, das ist, ähm, oh, jetzt hab ich seinen Namen vergessen, tut mir leid, aber es ist ein sozusagen komplett von Grund auf nachgeschriebenes PGP von einem Deutschen. Und ähm, das funktioniert halt einen Tick besser als das original PGP. Der PGP-Sourcecode ist teilweise ziemlich grauenhaft, was die nicht kryptographischen Teile angeht. Also wenn man mal versucht hat, PGP in irgendwelche anderen Set-ups einzubinden, wird man das merken. Und, ähm, ja, man kann Gnu-PG durchaus gut in gewissen benutzen, da Gnu-PG auch im Sourcecode vorliegt und sich das genügend Leute angeguckt haben. Es gibt jetzt auch das RFC zu PGP, Open-PGP, mit dem auch der Standard jetzt mal festgelegt wurde, wie die Formate aussehen, wie der Schlüsselaustausch funktioniert und so weiter und so fort. Also Gnu-PG kann man durchaus weiterempfehlen, gibt es für richtige Computer, nicht für die mit den grafischen Nutzeroberflächen.
Das heißt das ist für Linux?
Ja, für Linux und für alle anderen, wo man...
GSD, alles was irgendwie mit X aufhört und...
Genau. Mac OS X zum Beispiel.
Mac OS X muss man auch fahren können. Ja, aber Windows irgendwie, ein weiterer Grund Windows von der Festplatte zu nehmen.
Man muss trotzdem ab und zu in der Zwischenzeit, dass trotz der ganzen Abkürzung und also trotz des DbP fürs Apd, keine Ahnung, muss man trotzdem ab und zu mal dazu sagen, dass der Weg einer verschlüsselten Mail nicht so kompliziert ist, wie das alles jetzt hier klingt.
Man könnte ja auch mal vielleicht die voll ausgeschriebenen...
Bezeichnungen verwenden.
PGP heißt Pretty Good Privacy. Nach dem Motto, das war schon mal ganz gut. Und GPG steht für GNU Privacy Guard. So, aber letzten Endes wird man sich eh nur über diese ganzen Abkürzungen. Also wenn ihr irgendwas mit drei Buchstaben, wo irgendwie Gs und Ps drin vorkommen, dann handelt es sich um Verschlüsselung.
Nicht einfach.
Du sollst aber LP gehackt haben.
Du wolltest ja nicht zu schwer machen, nicht wahr?
Und auch die BVG ist Might-Entertainment.
Ja, die gehört eher dem anderen Lager an, wenn sie dann erstmal elektronische Karten anstellt.
Die Bedienung, die heutzutage, das Know-how, das heutzutage zur Bedienung eines Fahrkartenautomatens notwendig geworden ist, anguckt.
Schon recht kryptisch, ja.
Um beim Thema zu bleiben, welche Verschlüsselungsprodukte taugen was und welche nicht, also wenn man ein Produkt kommerziell aus den USA erwirbt, dann kann man eigentlich hundertprozentig davon ausgehen, dass es nichts taugt. Eben wegen der Exportrestriktion in den USA. Die dürfen nur solche Sachen exportieren, die auch nachweislich zu knacken sind. So wurde jetzt Ovi großzügig die erlaubte Schlüssellänge von 40 auf 56 bitt heraufgesetzt. Das passierte ungefähr einen Monat, nachdem die EFF, die Electronic Frontier Foundation, einen Desknacker gebaut hat und nachgewiesen hat, dass man innerhalb weniger Tage mit einem Hardware-Aufwand unter einer Million einen solchen 56 bit key knacken kann. Das bedeutet natürlich, dass die Leute, die mehr als eine Million zur Verfügung haben, NSA und die ganzen anderen Geheimdienste, selbstverständlich in der Lage sind, solche Schlüssel in Echtzeit zu knacken. Also wenn man wie ein Super Security Krypt File Protector Plus sich zulegt und das aus einem Land bezieht, dann kann man davon ausgehen, dass es nichts taugt. Wenn man sich irgendwelche Shareware aus dem Netz holt, zu der es keinen Source Code gibt, dann kann es zwar sein, dass der Autor das gut gemeint hat und dass er vielleicht auch den richtigen Algorithmus verwendet, aber dass er leider irgendwo ein kleines Problem in seinem Schlüsselmanagement hat usw. Also auch davon sollte man Abstand nehmen. Und wenn man es genau wissen will, sollte man sich das Buch von Bruce Schneider zulegen, Applied Cryptography, da steht eigentlich zu jedem Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus drin, ob er was taugt, wie viel er taugt usw. Das ist schonmal ein Anhaltspunkt, wenn man also den Source Code von einem Programm hat, wenn ein Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus verwendet wird, von dem allgemein angenommen wird, dass er sicher ist, also IDEA z.B. oder Trippeldes oder Blowfish oder CAST oder so. Das sind die 5, 6 wichtigsten, Symmetrischen und dann noch RSA und DSS usw. Dann hat man eine relativ gute Chance, dass man eine Software erwischt hat, die auch was taugt. Dann kann es natürlich immer noch sein, dass es irgendwas Unbekanntes ist und man ein bisschen Pech bei der Implementation hat usw. Also wenn man auch eine Software verwendet, die viele Leute benutzen und die viele Leute sich angeguckt haben, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass da ein Problem existiert am geringsten. Also PGP ist schon deshalb auch die ganzen PGP-Klone relativ gut erforscht und das Schlüsselmanagement ist gut verstanden, das Fallformat ist erforscht usf. Das heißt, dass man da eigentlich davon ausgehen kann, dass das schon funktioniert.
Also bei kommerzieller Verschlüsselungssoftware kann man so als Faustregel eigentlich immer davon ausgehen, also bei Software, wo man den Sourcecode nicht hat, dass jeweils der Geheimdienst des Landes, aus dem die Software kommt, mitlesen kann. So als Faustregel.
Gut, machen wir das Ganze jetzt nochmal verständlich für Leute, die gerade mal und die halbwegs ihr E-Mail-Programm im Griff haben. Zu welcher Webadresse gehen die und welche Plugins für ihren Mailer besorgen die sich am besten?
Es gibt ja eine einfache Antwort.
Wir wollen ja dazu auffordern, dass alle möglichen Leute das bewerben.
Und wir wollen ja nicht, dass wir jetzt sagen, kauft euch jetzt diese Packung oder kauft euch jetzt diese Packung. Dann brauchst du nichts kaufen. Aber auch nicht nehmt diese Packung oder nehmt diese Packung, sondern wir wollen den Leuten sagen, wie sie die unterschiedlichen Packungen in Bezug auf die Qualität bewerten können. Und es gibt halt Packungen, da steht Sicherheit drauf. Und Packungen, wo Sicherheit drauf steht, die man aber nicht aufmachen kann, will sagen, wo man jetzt ausgucken und nicht lesen kann, die lässt man besser gleich stehen. Weil es gibt eben ne Menge Leute, die treiben damit schabernack. Gerade die, die dann Sicherheitsbewusstsein haben, kaufen dann irgendwas und glauben, das ist sicher. Sie können aber nicht reingucken und das ist Quatsch. Die Firma Krypto AG ist da so ein bisschen das Beispiel, auch wenn das jetzt ein bisschen wieder von der praktischen Handwerke wegkommt. Das ist ne Firma in der Schweiz, die lange Zeit so als neutrale Institution galt, wenn es um Verschlüsselungsprodukte ging. Da könnte man als Firma, auch als Privatperson hingehen, ein bisschen Geld auf den Tisch legen und dann bekam man irgendeine Kiste, auf der stand Sicherheit und Verschlüsselung drauf. In Wirklichkeit gehört die Firma Krypto AG über eine Holding der Bundesrepublik Deutschland und die Algorithmen, die da drin sind, werden von der NSA reingeschraubt. Das ist alles ein wenig tolles Kapitel der Geschichte der Firma Krypto AG. Ja, und der Tipp lautet, dass man erst mal irgendwie Produkte eben unterstützt und auch benutzt, wo man eben reingucken kann. Und ob man das dann versteht, was da drin rumgeht oder nicht, ist erstmal insofern nur bedingt, wesentlich, dass es oftmals genügt jemanden zu kennen, der versteht, was drin vorgeht. Das ist genauso wie beim Auto. Also ich meine, muss auch nicht jeder wissen, wie das Auto funktioniert, das er fährt. Aber es sollte zumindest einen Hebel haben zum Aufmachen, damit man einen Freund, der davon was versteht, reingucken kann und sagen kann, so so.
Aber trotzdem haben wir natürlich ein, wir haben ja grundsätzlich ein Problem bei der Vorgehensweise bei diesen Sachen. Weil, sagen wir mal so, AOL ist sicher bei Weitem kein Internetprovider, den man wählen sollte. Er ist aber weit verbreitet als ehemaliges abgeschlossenes System und inzwischen auch sich ein bisschen öffnendes System zum Internet, weil es super simpel ist. Weil Leute irgendwo draufklicken, weil es sich fast gut installiert und weil man überall Buttons hat, wo man draufklickt und halbwegs genau weiß, was man machen muss im Gegensatz zu einem Tenant-Fenster oder zu einer Eigeninstallation von weiß ich nicht, was man alles braucht. Und deswegen denke ich, wäre es schon gut, wenn wir ein paar Hinweise geben, zumindest zwei, drei Startadressen.
Ja, also einen Tipp kann man geben. Also für Bunty Clicky empfehle ich www.pgpi.com Das I ist da sehr wichtig. Das ist nämlich die International Website von PGP und dort finden sich die Programme von PGP, die zuletzt per Buch exportiert wurden. Es gibt da eine Version 5.3.i. Wichtig. Die ist zu empfehlen, insofern, dass sie erstens den alten Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus RSA noch unterstützt und damit eben die Kompatibilität auch zu allen anderen Hackern irgendwie sicherstellt, die selbstverständlich noch die alte Software unter Unix zum Beispiel verwenden, die nach wie vor prima funktioniert. Nur, dass diese 553i jetzt für Bunty Clicky den Vorteil hat, dass sie sich hervorragend in die gängigen E-Mail-Programme integriert. Also bei Windows und bei Macintosh ist dann das Benutzen von PGP, also von RSA, Schlüssel, sag ich mal, kein großes Problem mehr.
Man sollte auch dazu sagen, dass für Leute, die den Begriff Bunty Clicky vielleicht abwertend empfinden, muss man dazu sagen, dass Tim starker Verrechter von Bunty Clicky Betriebssystem ist.
Also es gibt auch Leute, die behaupten, es handele sich sozusagen um eine Schimpansen-kompatible Benutzer, aber Fläche, was so viel bedeutet, wie. Man muss eben nicht mehr bis ins letzte Bit verstehen, was die Maschine macht. Man kann sich das Produkt nehmen und das fährt sich danach wie Mercedes mit Automatikgetriebe irgendwie. Man stellt auch Fahrt.
Diese Diskussion, dafür gibt es einen schönen Workshop auf dem Chaos Communication Congress, der schreibt, der Betriebssystem immer gelistet, also auch für den Unterhaltungswert. Aber ich finde, aber genau das ist mir nicht...
Vielleicht wirst du den Workshop, den man einlande, immer den Ausbruch festschwadern, bei der Wartung.
Das ist wirklich ein Kernproblem von Leuten, die sich zu viel mit Technik beschäftigen, finde ich. Also weil es muss benutbar, einfach benutbar sein. Sonst niemand wird seine E-Mail verschlüsseln.
Das mit dem Schimpansen-Kompatibel, das ist ja auch jetzt nicht abwertend gemeint.
Wir fördern die Privatsphäre für Schimpansen.
Ja, nein, ich meine, ich würde also das Problem... Sie haben gesagt, dass der Begriff ein bisschen superiert, dass wir den Menschen vor dem Computer verhört halten. Aber was damit ja letztendlich gemeint ist, es gibt halt eine lange Diskussion, die mit der Einführung grafischer Benutzer oder Flächen so aufkam. Da gab es so eine Art alte Garde der Computerbriefe, die eben gesagt haben, also ist das denn irgendwie okay, dass jetzt Leute so eine Maschine benutzen und einfach gar nicht mehr wissen, was drin passiert und auch davon eben abhängig dann werden und damit auch abhängig werden von Leuten, die davon was verstehen, wie es eben mit den Autos genauso ist.
Du hast jetzt vier Minuten Zeit zu erklären, wie Radio funktioniert.
Wie Radio funktioniert?
Also so über den Daumen, muss nicht so genau sein, also Antwort.
Also ich fahr zehn Minuten vorher, fährt man zur Tanke, Koffer und...
Nein, es ging jetzt kurz um die Frage, was empfiehlt man den Menschen vor der Maschine und entweder man hält sich an ein Reh, hat seine Definition, holt sich irgendwie Pgp, kombiniert das selbst und alles ist gut oder eben man hat einen Computer, den man in erster Linie als Werkzeug sieht und wo man auch nicht den Anspruch hat, zum Computerfreak zu werden, sondern man möchte sehr wohl E-Mail benutzen und man möchte auch sehr wohl diese E-Mail verschlüsseln und dann zieht man sich eben ein Programm mit grafischer Benutzeroberfläche, was es jetzt für Pgp dankenswerterweise auch gibt. Man muss also auch nicht mehr das große, dicke Buch von Bruce Schneier, Applied Cryptography gelesen haben, um Verschlüsselung zu benutzen. Es ist tatsächlich so einfach wie einen Briefumschlag um einen Brief legen.
Genau. Wir sagen euch nicht, bei welchen Themen wir hier gerade sind, während die Musik läuft, sondern wir sagen euch, dass das Thema heute im Chaos Radio, dem monatlichen Computer-Blummen hier bei Fritz, Kryptografie und Privatsphäre heißt. Diese Sendung findet übrigens eigentlich immer jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat statt, außer wenn er wie im Vorvormonat ausfällt oder wie vor einer Woche verschoben wird um eine Woche und deswegen nämlich genau heute stattfindet. Oder außer wenn es Dezember ist, dann findet er nämlich nicht statt, außer er ist verschoben und findet da Anfall statt. Aber an sich?
Und wenn dann nicht gerade C-Bit ist, dann bitte referieren Sie jetzt die Regeln für Schaltjahre zu Jahrhundertwenden.
Man könnte sich hier vielleicht auch noch mal kurz die Standards sagen. Wir haben eine Homepage, wer es noch nicht weiß, chaosradio.ccc.de, wo alles um Chaos Radio ist. Wir haben einen Mail-Ankündigungsverteiler, der heißt Chaos Radio Ticker. Alle Informationen dazu findet ihr eben auf dieser Homepage, dort wird jeweils anstehende Sendungen rechtzeitig angekündigt. Also da hat man auch die Möglichkeit mit den Unregelmäßigkeiten klarzukommen.
Und was der Tim leider nicht hat, wo er hier gerade am referieren ist, ist eine Haarschneidemaschine und wenn ein Hörer eine über hat, dann soll er uns die mal dringend rüber schicken.
Ach Andi, du bist doch auf dem Neuzierenden hingegen.
Falls er aber noch Shampoo hat, könnte er das Andi schicken. Ich will es nicht unerwähnt lassen, dass es auch für den Kongress und überhaupt alles, was wichtig ist, noch eine andere Mailingliste gibt, die heißt Chaos Update. Das findet ihr auf unserer Homepage. So, jetzt hab ich auch, die halte ich gerne, das Kmall, Andi.
Gut, dann kann Andreas ja jetzt noch ein klein bisschen dazu sagen, warum PGP leider nicht immer PGP ist oder warum wir so explizit darauf beharren, dass ihr bitte die internationalen Versionen von PGP benutzt, nämlich die, die von GWW PGP-I kommen und nicht die amerikanischen Versionen.
Und es kam gerade auch in dem Zusammenhang noch die Frage nach der 6.0-Version. Vielleicht kannst du das mit einfließen lassen.
Ja genau, nun ist es natürlich so, dass PGP bei gewissen Leuten ziemlich unbeliebt ist und da wird gerade die übliche Microsoft-Strategie gefahren, Embrace und Extend. Das heißt, dass PGP jetzt von einer etwas größeren Firma namens Network Associates gekauft wurde und die wiederum Mitglied oder vielleicht doch nicht oder vielleicht doch in der Key Recovery Alliance sind. Letzten Endes, wie es ist, ist es auf jeden Fall so, dass da ein politischer Druck auf die ausgeübt wird, da eine Hinterlegung von Schlüsseln einzubauen, damit man im Notfall halt doch entschlüsseln kann. Und je nachdem, was gerade für Wetter ist, wird das verschieden benannt. Das wird mal irgendwie Key Recovery benannt. Und bei PGP heißt es dann Corporate Message Recovery. Und Corporate Message Recovery ist einfach ein Feature, dass wenn man an jemanden etwas verschlüsselt, in seinem Schlüssel drinne steht, bitte verschlüssel das doch an diesen oder jeden Schlüssel auch noch mit. Und die Argumentation ist dann, ja, das ist gut, dass wenn einer in der Firma ist, eine verschlüsselte E-Mail kriegt und dann wird er vom Bus überfahren, dass man die doch lesen kann. Und das ist aber alles nicht so ganz tief und stich fest, weil man ja immer noch die Mails, die man bekommt, entschlüsseln kann und entschlüsselt abspeichern kann. Dann können die Mitarbeiter daran oder man kann sie, wenn man sie verschlüsselt abspeichern will, mit einem sogenannten Storage Key speichern. Das ist also alles nicht ganz tief und stich fest. Und nun schwören sie immer, ja, das ist überhaupt gar kein Problem, aber so richtig trauen kann man der ganzen Geschichte nicht. Zusätzlich gibt es da bei den neueren PGP-Versionen, vielleicht ist es dem einen oder anderen aufgefallen, eine sogenannte Message-ID. Und diese Message-ID ist eine Zufallszahl. Und es gibt in PGP einen Mechanismus, um Zufallszahlen zu erzeugen. Der wird aber auch benutzt, um den Session-Key für diese Message zu ermitteln. Das heißt, da wird erst der Schlüssel, mit dem diese Nachricht verschlüsselt wird, aus dem Topf mit den Zufallszahlen genommen. Dann direkt danach die Message-ID, die im Klartext für jeden lesbar ist. Und jetzt sagen sie natürlich auch hoch und heilig, ja, also es ist ja überhaupt gar kein Problem und man kann dann aus den einen Zufallszahlen nicht die anderen errechnen, aber wer weiß das letzten Endes, ob das nicht vielleicht doch geht, ob da nicht vielleicht ein Back drin ist, ob sie dann Verfahren haben und so weiter und so fort. Und aus diesem Grund ist es günstig, die internationale Version sich zu holen, weil die erstens im Source-Code vorliegt und zweitens dann diese Features, Corporate Message Recovery und Message ID, da nicht eingeschaltet sind. Und zusätzlich ist es ja so, dass sie bei dem Übergang von PGP2 auf PGP5 bzw. 6 die Verschlüsselungsverfahren geändert haben und dann gab es halt Übergangsversionen, die konnten sowohl das alte als auch das neue Format und jetzt gibt es halt einige Versionen, die können nur noch das neue Format und damit ist man halt einfach zum Rest der Welt inkompatibel. Und auch aus diesem Grund sollte man das dann nicht verwenden.
Wobei sie da ein bisschen, das ging so ein bisschen hin und her, also die 5.0er, damit fing der ganze Arger an, die hat halt den alten traditionellen Verschlüsselungsweg, nämlich RSA, einfach weggelassen. Man konnte also zwar wohl RSA entschlüsseln, aber man konnte sich selber kein RSA-Key machen, sodass man selber nur einen Schlüssel verwenden konnte, der wiederum mit neuen Versionen von PGP überhaupt zu lesen war. Damit wollte man sozusagen andere Leute zwingen, auch auf die neueste Version von PGP zu gehen. Dann haben sie in einer anderen Version irgendwie RSA. Also ich glaube bei der 6er ist nämlich RSA komplett draußen. Ist das richtig?
Das muss ich mir nochmal genau angucken. Ich habe die 6er mal installiert und hatte da irgendwelche komische Probleme, dass man zum Beispiel mit meinem Key, also an meinen Key, nichts schicken konnte. Und ich habe ein RSA-Key.
Also ich glaube, es gibt da gewisse Probleme. Auf jeden Fall ist es eben auch sehr unklar. Und wie die Firma NAI oder PGP, wie man es auch nennen soll, wie die das kommuniziert, das ist eben auch ziemlich komisch. Sie bringen Updates von ihrer Software. Die 6.0er ist zum Beispiel auf der Website erschienen. Ja, es gibt jetzt eine neue Version und die können Sie ja jetzt mal kaufen. Aber es stand da einfach überhaupt kein Wort, was in dieser Version neu ist oder was die kann oder was sie nicht mehr kann. Und genau da entsteht das Problem. Die Proteste waren dann relativ groß. Diese Version 553i, die ich vorhin erwähnt habe, die kann beides. Und man sollte sich halt auch einen RSA-Schlüssel machen, solange man noch mit anderen Leuten kommuniziert, die eine alte Version von PGP haben, die die neuen DH DSS Schlüssel noch nicht kennen.
So.
Die Musik kommt, und das kann man ja auch ab und zu nochmal dazu sagen, heute vom Analog Club DJ Team Kraftwerk.
Ja, vielleicht verlegen wir noch ein paar Worte zu dieser Firma Network Associates, die ja doch öfter erwähnt wurde. Die Firma ist insofern interessant, weil die sich langsam aber sicher zu einer Art Monopolisten im Sicherheitsbereich entwickelt. Also die Firma ist eigentlich entstanden, ursprünglich als eine von vielen Firmen, die sich halt mit Computersicherheit beschäftigt haben. Unterscheidet sich aber dadurch von allmöchen anderen Firmen, dass sie eine extrem aggressive Einkaufsstrategie betreibt. Das ist so, dass die mittlerweile über 100 verschiedene Sicherheitsprodukte, die auf dem Markt waren, ursprünglich als unabhängige Produkte oder unabhängige Firmen eingekauft haben und die jetzt halt unter Network Associates vertreiben. Also die haben halt mittlerweile alles von Firewalls über Intrusion Detection, über irgendwelche Black Boxes, die Verschlüsselungen machen, über Software wie PGP und so weiter und so fort. Und die haben da halt tatsächlich auch etliche Firmen dabei, die halt irgendwie nicht nur von Staatsaufträgen leben. Und die Firma ist halt insofern suspekt, als dass die Geschwindigkeit, mit der die den Markt aufkaufen, doch ziemlich abnorm ist. Die stellen sich interessanterweise im Vertrieb ziemlich dumm an. Also es ist so, dass die zum Beispiel in Deutschland, wenn man damit zum Network of Societs Vertreter redet und von denen irgendein Produkt haben will, muss man schon ziemlich genau wissen, welches Produkt man haben will. Man kann da nicht hingehen und sagen, irgendwie, ich hab dieses und jenes Problem, empfehlen sie mir doch mal was. Sondern die haben tatsächlich mittlerweile einen so dermaßen fetten Musterkoffer von Sicherheitsprodukten, dass sie da selber nicht mehr durchblicken, was halt den Verdacht ziemlich nahelegt, dass die Produkte im Wesentlichen eingekauft wurden, um sie unter Kontrolle zu bringen. Naja, und da spielt halt natürlich noch eine Rolle diese Key Recovery Association.
Ja, also dazu muss man wiederum kurz zurückkommen zu diesen amerikanischen Exportregulierung. Mit dem neuen Gesetz, das jetzt eben vom Wirtschaftsministerium der USA, also vom Department of Commerce 1996-97 ausgearbeitet wurde, also Anfang 97 in Kraft getreten ist, ist sozusagen der Plan formuliert worden, innerhalb von zwei Jahren diese Key Recovery Funktion, das heißt, ein Teil des Schlüssels wird den verschlüsselten Nachrichten beigelegt, zu verwirklichen und es wurde also den amerikanischen Firmen mehr oder weniger freigestellt, innerhalb von zwei Jahren doch tun und zu lassen, was sie wollen mit ihren Produkten, solange sie sich eben verpflichten, nach Ablauf dieser zwei Jahren eben diese Funktionen einzubauen. Und das ist sozusagen der eine Zweig und der andere ist, dass die amerikanische Regierung selbst dann noch sich überlegt hat, wie sie dann mit den Firmen umgeht, die da irgendwie keine Lust drauf haben. Und es ist schlicht und ergreifend so, dass wenn man als amerikanische Firma oder auch als europäische Firma der amerikanischen Regierung vielleicht irgendetwas verkaufen möchte im Computertechnikbereich, ich nehme mal an, irgendeine Polizeistation in den USA möchte einen Computer von der Firma Siemens erwerben oder so etwas, dann wird eben erst einmal mit einer bestimmten Liste überprüft, ob denn diese Firma sich auch verpflichtet hat, diese Anordnung der amerikanischen Regierung und des Wirtschaftsministeriums einzuhalten. Und um das sozusagen alles organisatorisch zu vereinfachen, wurde die KRA gegründet. Die KRA heißt ausgeschrieben Key Recovery Alliance. Das ist eben unter www.kra.org zu finden. Bis vor wenigen Wochen war die Firma Siemens Deutschland interessanterweise dort auch Mitglied. Das ist sozusagen der Verband der Unternehmen, die, wie sie selbst bekunden, also freiwillig im vorauseilenden Gehorsam sozusagen gerne die Anforderungen der amerikanischen Regierung in Bezug auf die Mitlesbarkeit von verschlüsselten Nachrichten erfüllen. Und das ist sozusagen dieser eine Zweig. Es ist übrigens sehr interessant, sich anzugucken, wer so Mitglied ist und wer nicht. Und leider ist eben die Firma NetRack, die jetzt die PGP gekauft hat, da auch Mitglied. Auch wenn sie immer wieder behauptet, davon wäre PGP ja überhaupt nicht betroffen. Das ist also nicht ganz klar. Was jetzt die Auswirkung auf uns sozusagen Europäer oder Deutsche oder wie wir es auch immer formulieren, ist, da gibt es noch einen anderen Zweig. Dieses Gesetz des Amerikanischen heißt interessanterweise Global Key Recovery und so weiter und so fort gesetzt. Und Global suggeriert dann nun, dass der ganze Planet betroffen ist und damit eben die Regierung, die ja eigentlich, also die Regierung anderer Staaten, die ja eigentlich nicht unmittelbar weisungsbefugt, also wo die amerikanische Regierung nicht unmittelbar weisungsbefugt ist, anderen Regierungen irgendwelche Befehle mitzuteilen. So zumindest die Theorie in der Praxis, die das enthäusst, dass es einen US-Sonderbotschafter gibt, den Herrn Aaron. Der Herr Aaron ist der Sonderbeauftragte der US-Regierung für die Durchsetzung dieses Planes und der besucht von Zeit zu Zeit immer mal wieder deutsche und andere hochrangige Regierungsvertreter von europäischen Staaten. Er war das letzte, also beziehungsweise das vorletzte Mal, war Ende 1996 da. Damals hat er Canter und Kohl besucht, also den damaligen Innenminister und den Bundeskanzler und hat eben sozusagen die auf die Linie des großen Bruders, wollte ich jetzt schon fast sagen, ist es ja irgendwie auch, als er sich der deutschen Regierung bringt und ihn eben für die amerikanischen Regierungspläne mit als Partner gewinnt. Canter hat ja sozusagen auch vollzug gemeldet und hat das dann versucht, indem er ja das laute als verkündet hat, man müsse jetzt und so weiter und so fort. Nachdem er jetzt erstmal gescheitert ist und ja auch die ganze Regierung irgendwie gescheitert ist und abgewählt wurde, haben wir jetzt ja den Herrn Schilli da als Innenminister sitzen. Und wir haben eine weitere wichtige Schlüssefigur, das ist der Herr Moosdorf. Der ist der ehemalige Leiter der Enquete-Kommission Deutschlands Weg in die Informationsgesellschaft. Jemand, also aus der SPD-Fraktion, der jetzt im Wirtschaftsministerium sitzt. Und der wurde gerade vor ein paar Wochen wieder von Herrn Aaron besucht. Der Schilly auch und ein paar andere auch. Und der Herr Aaron hat die jetzt wiederum instruiert oder auf Linie gebracht. Oder wie man es auch immer formuliert. Also die sozusagen diplomatischen Empfindlichkeiten der amerikanischen Regierung dort kommuniziert. Und das heißt ganz konkret, dass wir schon davon ausgehen, dass in den nächsten Wochen da mal wieder was passiert. Dass also Herr Schilly oder wer auch immer da auf die Idee kommt, werden uns doch noch mal diese ganze Technologie zumindest in die Diskussion zu zerren. Mit dem Versuch, also dass da ein Gesetz bei herauskommt, was eben die freie Verschlüsselung untersagt oder zumindest nur den Verkauf solcher Produkte als zulässig deklariert, wo eben der Staat mitlesen kann. Das können wir jetzt alles noch nicht so richtig absehen, aber zumindest ist da einiges am Mauscheln. Und es gibt gerade auch fraktionsinternen Streit, weil eigentlich die SPD in ihrem Parteiprogramm offenbar auch drinstehen hatte, dass es eine Regulierung von Kryptografie damit nicht geben wird. Aber wie das bei Leuten an der Macht so ist, das interessiert mich mal ein Geschwätz von gestern. Also wir werden sehen, was da irgendwie bei rauskommt.
Diese T-Cavary Alliance erinnert mich noch sehr an den Film Brasil. Jetzt ist mir klar, was mit der Informationswiederbeschaffung gemeint war.
Abkürzungen über Abkürzungen, Erklärungen über Erklärungen. Gleich so in etwa sieben Minuten gibt es noch mal ein Fritz-Kurzinfo. Und danach haben wir noch eine knappe halbe Stunde Zeit, um uns mit euch zu unterhalten. Was uns besonders interessiert ist, wie ist eure Einstellung zu dieser ganzen Geschichte? Werdet ihr anfangen, wenn ihr es noch nicht tut, werdet ihr anfangen eure E-Mail zu verschlüsseln. Auch wenn ihr in Anführungszeichen nichts zu verbergen habt, wie wir alle natürlich nichts zu verbergen haben. Einfach um dabei zu sein. Ich hab mich neulich jemand gefragt, hörst du deine Sendung manchmal selber?
Ja, mit sieben Sekunden.
Ich war mit sieben Sekunden verzögert.
Zumindest geht der Internet noch. Ja, der Internet liegt noch.
Und was wollte ich gerade noch sagen? Achso, genau, und habt ihr Erfahrung. Genau, nach dem Info habt ihr Erfahrung mit Verschlüsselungen. Benutzt ihr das schon?
Oder kommt euch das völlig überflüssig vor?
Kommt euch das überflüssig vor? Oder habt ihr zum Beispiel aus bestimmter Erfahrung dann angefangen, eure E-Mail zu verschlüsseln? Habt ihr da schon mal negative Erfahrungen gemacht oder so? Das alles dann bitte unter der üblichen Fritz-Nummer.
Die Fritz-Hotline ist geschaltet.
0331 für Potsdam.
7097 Um zum Telefongebühren zu sparen, solltet ihr das erst so ab 0.32 Uhr wählen.
Darfst du die Musik ruhig ein bisschen... Ach so, die erinnert das.
Ja, kann das nicht beeinflussen.
Also, wir verwenden ja auch Verschlüsselung und wir hatten vor allem jüngst das Problem, dass wir irgendwie... Also wir machen eigentlich viel Kommunikation über Mailinglisten und die waren halt immer nicht verschlüsselt. Das Problem ist, wenn man auf eine Mailingliste irgendwas schickt, dann kann man das ja nicht an alle Leute verschlüsseln, die da drauf sind, weil man erst nicht weiß, wer da drauf ist. Und geschweige denn, dass man von allen Leuten Schlüssel hat. Geschweige denn, dass alle Leute überhaupt einen Schlüssel haben. Jetzt haben wir da ein bisschen drumherum gebastelt und haben jetzt eine lauffähige Konfiguration. Also eine Konfiguration, von der wir glauben, dass sie lauffähig ist. Ich weiß nicht, inwieweit ist die von QML und EZMLM abhängig?
Sehr?
Das Mikro ist nicht an? Mach doch mal.
Jetzt ist es an. Ich wusste nicht, dass die erst noch anfangen zu diskutieren vor dem Info.
Wir hatten eben gesagt, wir spielen Musik.
Na ja, aber wenn Tim eine Frage hat, dann möchte ich ihm noch gerne antworten. Also es ist so in der Tat, dass es sehr abhängig ist von QML und EasyMM, wo ich gar nicht mehr was dagegen habe, weil Send-Me sowieso eine grauenhaft schlechte Software mit so vielen Hintertüren ist, dass es schon nicht mehr feierlich ist. Also wenn man QML einsetzt, dann kann man auch EasyMM einsetzen für das Mailing-Listen-Management. Und dann kann man unsere Mailing-Listen-Verschlüsselungssoftware da rein basteln. Die liegt bei uns auf dem CVS-Server. Das ist einfach www.ccc.de auf Port 24.01. Einfach mal mann.cvs eingeben, da steht das drin im Verzeichnis EasyMLM-PGP. Und da wird es demnächst auch eine Webseite dazu geben, die wird dann von der Homepage von www.ccc.de verlinkt sein.
Und damit kann man halt verschlüsselte Mailing-Listen machen. Das heißt, man hat ein automatisches System, wo sich jemand einträgt in die Liste mit seinem Public Key. Und man verschlüsselt dann mit dem Public Key der Liste an die Liste. Und die Liste selber wiederum verschlüsselt dann alle eingetragenen Leute diese Mail, sodass auf der gesamten Wegstrecke der Mail die Mail verschlüsselt ist, auf dem Hinweg mit dem Schlüssel der Liste und auf dem Rückweg mit dem Schlüssel aller Teilnehmer. Und naja, wir werden das halt öffentlich verfügbar machen, damit sich das verbreitet.
Mehr Info dazu dann unter www.ccc.de C-Kontakt. Mit der Forderung des ZDF für funk 2021 Manchmal frage ich mich, wie Radiosendungen wohl in fünf Jahren klingen werden. Vielleicht sagt man, da keine zusammenhängenden Wörter mehr, weil man spricht nur noch in Abkürzung. Statt mehr Info unter, sagt man dann MEU, MEU www.
Kennst du den Futololischen Kongress von Lem? Ist ein bisschen lange her. Da hatten sie das Problem, dass sie Diskussionszeit sparen müssten und dann gab es einen dicken Katalog von Argumenten und dann stellte sich der Räder vorne hin und sagte 17.000er Beifall. 23.425. Alle klatschen. 17.12. Beruf aus dem Publikum, 23. Vielen Dank und gut vorwärts.
Es ist 0 Uhr 31.
Vereinbarungen, die Regierungspartner SPD und Grüne wollen sich künftig regelmäßig zu Koalitionsrunden treffen. Das teilten die Fraktionschef zu Struck und Schlauch am Abend nach einem zweistündigen Gespräch von Spitzenvertretern beider Seiten im Bonner Kanzleramt mit. Die Koalitionsrunden sollen einmal pro Monat stattfinden. Unglück, bei einem Brand in einem Waisenhaus der philippinischen Hauptstadt Manila sind nach Angaben der Feuerwehr mindestens zehn Menschen ums Leben gekommen. Darunter seien acht Kinder, sagten Feuerwehrleute in Manila. Die Zahl der Opfer könne noch höher liegen. Brandursache soll ein Fehler in den Stromleitungen gewesen sein. Reaktion. Israel hat am Abend erneut den vereinbarten Truppenabzug aus dem Westjordanland gestoppt. Die Regierung begründete die Entscheidung mit dem Angriff einer palästinensischen Menge auf einen israelischen Soldaten bei Ramallah. Einschränkungen. Deutsche Touristen sind von der neuen polnischen Devisenverordnung ausgenommen. Das Innenministerium in Warschau versicherte, dass Bundesbürger auch künftig bei der Einreise nach Polen kein Geld vorweisen müssen. Die neue Regelung solle vor allem bei Reisenden aus Osteuropa angewendet werden. Massaker. In Algerien sind wieder zwölf Zivilisten ermordet worden. Wie der staatliche Rundfunk heute meldete, sind die Opferbewohner eines abgelegenen Dorfes. Die Bluttat habe sich in der vergangenen Nacht ereignet. Als Täter werden islamistische Extremistische vermutet.
Sport.
Fußball. Im Viertelfinale des DFB Pokals verlor Tennis Bursa bei Werder Bremen 1 zu 2. Rot-Weiß Oberhausen bezwang Bursa Mönchengladbach 2 zu 0. In einem Nachholspiel der Champions League trennten sich Galatasaray, Istanbul und Juventus Turin 1 zu 1. Zu den befürchteten Ausschreitungen in Istanbul kam es nicht. Heute Nacht bedeckt etwa Schneegriesel bei minus 6 bis minus 10 Grad. Morgen teils Heiter und trocken minus 5 bis minus 1 Grad.
Keine aktuellen Meldungen, gute Fahrt für euch.
Das war ein Fritz Kurz Info mit Gerae Zcote Heinrich.
Fritz präsentiert elektronische Musik, die rockt.
Die Harvest Label Nacht ab 12.12. Dr. Walker von Air Liquide und M-Flux. Computer Jockeys.
Das Schöne ist, dass ich von hier aus, wo wir doch www.fritz.de sind, den Server nicht mehr erreiche, was aber glaube ich eher bei uns liegt an sich. Obwohl, nee, ich hab Quartell net probiert, die Verbindung selber funktioniert. Ich hab keine Ahnung woran es dient, es ist mir auf Scheiß egal.
Naja, unser Chat auf www.zzcde läuft auf jeden Fall noch.
Aber ich hab das Gefühl im Raum, wir sind da hängen Leute schon vier Minuten in der Telefonleitung und der im Sekretariator, der ist irgendwie weg, ne? Schleft der unter dem Tisch?
Der ist kein Sekretariator.
Nein, nein, hier ist alles im Griff.
Der Kollege von Nightside ist auch schon da.
Ich weiß, die technischen Probleme sind gelöst. Die Lapserven sind irgendwie platt und...
Naja, die... Die EDV-Abteilung hat um 17 Uhr Feierabend, ist doch wohl klar.
Also, die haben so erzählt, dass sie heute Nachtschicht machen.
Tatsächlich?
Ja, Lutz vielleicht, klar.
Der macht oft Nachtschicht.
Ich glaube, die sind da gerade wirklich am Wirken.
Au, nein, nicht, dass ich da einen aufs Dach kriege, wenn ich so viel... Bestimmt.
Ich meine, nachher funktioniert dein Computer hier im Stuhl nicht mehr, wenn du so viel schimmst, he?
Macht nichts, hab ich weniger zu tun hier. Ist ja so, dass wir diese ganze heraufbeschworene digitale Welt und die mehr Medien, die führen nur dazu, dass ich hier noch mehr Knöpfe und noch mehr Regler hab. Brauch ich gar nicht. Ey, mir reichen zwei Plattenspieler, ein Mikro...
Punkt.
Reicht mir.
Echt?
Ja, und ein kleines Mischpunkt. Natürlich mit drei Reglern fürs Mikro und für die beiden Plattenspieler.
Und wir könnten ja nochmal ein Chaos Radio machen, Chaos Radio Spezial, warum Computer eigentlich sinnlos sind.
Und zwar ohne Strom, dieses Chaos Radio Spezial.
Wir könnten mal versuchen, irgendwo ein analoges Chaos Radio auf die Reihe zu knallen. Wird extrem schwierig.
Wieso? Wir nehmen einfach die Computer nicht mit. Wir benutzen keine Telefone.
Wir benutzen keine CDs. Alles nur Nöte.
Ich hab dir das nicht neulich gerade gemacht, bei 75 Jahre Radio, so mit dem alten Equipment senden.
Hat er noch so Möschfunk-Sender aufgetrieben oder was?
Nee, das war von völlig woanders gesendet.
Alte Rundfunkanscheidung.
Das ist schon ein altes Equipment.
Und kein Klasse, oder?
Ich war da nicht bei, aber hat trotzdem alles funktioniert. Kann man Radio mitmachen.
So, jetzt haben wir noch 20 Minuten. Und dann sind da noch so dumme Einfälle. Hören wir einfach mal euch, was so eure Erfahrungen sind mit Verschlüsselungssoftware.
Genau, da sind auch schon Leute negative am Anrufen.
Wir können noch lustige Geschichten, spannende Sachen.
Hallo, wer ist denn da? Hier ist Chaos Radio.
Ich hab noch mal eine Frage zu diesen Telekommunikationen, also Sachen, die er vorhin angesprochen hat. Und zwar muss ich beruflich häufig auch ein Handy benutzen und hab mit Kollegen öfters zu tun, die auch Handy benutzen. Und der eine sagte mir neulich, wenn du dein Handy angeschaltet auf dem Tisch liegen hast, kann einer passiv mithören, der die Technik dazu hat. Da wollte ich mal fragen, ob das jetzt stimmt. Weil wenn ich mit meinen Kumpels wieder mal einen Bankraub plane und das Handy dabei auf dem Tisch liegt, könnte das dann sein, dass die Polizei das mithört?
Naja, in jedem dieser Funktelefone steckt ja ein Computer. Und Computer werden von Software betrieben. Und genauso wie du die Software vom Computer ändern kannst, besteht zumindest theoretisch die Möglichkeit, dass man die Software in so einem Funktelefon dahingehend modifizieren kann, dass man es tatsächlich als Wanze gebrauchen kann. Also wir haben natürlich nicht den definitiven Beweis dafür, dass es so ist. Es gibt aber mindestens zwei Fälle in den USA, wo halt solche Dinge tatsächlich nachvollzogen wurden. Und es gibt die sichere Information, dass mit Verfassungsschutz in den Bürogebäuden die Funktelefone vorne beim Fördner abgegeben werden müssen. Ja, so viel sozusagen dazu.
Was immer das heißt dann.
Also wenn man davor Angst hat, also erstens ist es natürlich so, dass es nicht besonders viel Sinn macht, dieses Telefon zum Abhören zu verwenden, es sei denn als letzte Möglichkeit, weil nach einer Stunde ist einfach der Akku alle. Und wenn man tatsächlich befürchtet, man wird über sein Funktelefon abgehört, gibt es für 20 Mark einen Zugehörhandel, so kleine, lustige Geräte zu kaufen, die dann anfangen zu blinken, wenn man mit dem Telefon telefoniert. Und die kann man einfach daneben stellen. Wenn sie dann die ganze Zeit blinken, ohne dass man dieses Telefon benutzt, ohne dass man es bewegt usw. dann wird man darüber abgehört. Aber eigentlich ist es relativ unwahrscheinlich.
Das setzt aber voraus, dass du davon ausgehst, dass man den GSM-Teil als GSM-Teil benutzt. Ich meine, du weißt, wie hochintegriert diese Chips mittlerweile sind. Wir sind im Haftal, und die kann man, glaube ich, noch in ganz anderen Modi fahren.
Gut, und wenn ich das Ganze jetzt nochmal versuche, nicht technisch und dann juristisch zu beantworten, so ist das im jetzigen, beim jetzigen Stand des Telekommunikationsgesetzes nicht drin. Was allerdings drin ist, ist beispielsweise die Ortung des Standortes des Mobiltelefons und wen du anrufst und wann du dich angebucht hast und so weiter und fort. Also all diese Daten sind den Berechtigten, wie es da so schön ganz neutral heißt, verfügbar abrufbar, wie auch immer, zugänglich. Und was den Einsatz eines Mobiltelefons als Wanze betrifft, so zu sagen, so betrifft das wohl eher die Fälle, wo der Gesetzgeber, wie man so schön sagt, sich zwar irgendwelche von Wünsche, wie beispielsweise so Sachen wie Brief- und Fernweilegeheimnis, das unverletzlich irgendwann mal verschrieben hat, wo allerdings die Praxis eben andere Möglichkeiten bringt.
Das bringt uns aber doch schon zu einer interessanten Forderung, irgendwie Mitarbeiter auf Messeständen von irgendwie Mobilfunkunternehmen gucken immer ziemlich komisch, wenn man sie fragt, ob man auch den Source-Code für das Telefon bekommen kann. Ich würde euch allen empfehlen, das irgendwie auf der nächsten Messe dann auch gleich mal zu tun. Das dann irgendwann 30.000 Leute erzählen.
Ich würde vor allem empfehlen, das nicht auf der Messe zu machen, sondern irgendwie immer am besten.
Also E-Mails schicken, anrufen. Es kann einfach nicht angehen, dass man den Source-Code nicht bekommt für ein Telefon. Das mit einem Gerät, was man den ganzen Tag mit sich herumschleppt. Also Open Source.
Wie ist das mit diesen Kurzmitteilungen?
Wie ist das mit den Kurzmitteilungen?
Können die eigentlich auch abgehört werden?
Können schon. Sie fallen, ich sag mal so, sie sind im Gesetz im Moment nicht explizit drin. Das wurde offenbar übersehen. Sie fallen aber unter das, was die Begleitumstände der Telekommunikation heißen. Das heißt, es ist genauso wie die Standortdaten deines Mobiltelefons. Auch die sind sozusagen, stehen im Gesetz nicht explizit drin, sondern fallen unter die sogenannten Begleitdaten. Und somit sind sie auch von den berechtigten Abfragen oder Abruf oder wie auch immer, jedenfalls zugänglich.
Für solche Geschichten gibt es aber rechtlich. Braucht man dafür einen gerichtlichen Beschluss?
Nein. Wenn du im Verdacht stehst, Bestrebungen gegen die freiheitlich-demokratische Grundordnung zu hegen, dann ist beispielsweise der Verfassungsschutz oder wenn du im Verdacht stehst, irgendwie Bestrebungen gegen das Verstoß gegen das Kriegfass und Kontrollgesetz oder gegen sogar die äußere Sicherheit der Bundesrepublik Deutschland oder was auch immer. Also es gibt einen ganzen Riesenkatalog, der es eben den Geheimdiensten ohne den entsprechenden richterlichen Beschluss möglich macht, deine Daten abzurufen, zu speichern und so weiter und so fort.
Jo, das war's mal herzbar.
Ich fand ja mit den Analog-Sachen da vorhin eine witzige Bemerkung. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das wisst, dass die Berliner S-Bahn, die in den Zwoiszeiten noch gebaut wurde, die ich baue, jetzt 270 oder 485, die hatte einen riesen Analog- Rechner drin.
So mit Relais oder wie?
Bitte?
Mit Relais?
Ne, ne, ne, Rechner.
Widerstand sind zwei Kehr?
Richtig, analoge Schaltungen wurden dann in Formeln umgesetzt und damit auch die Schwindigkeits- und Fahrstufen- Regelung gemacht.
War das die, wo hinten diese tollen, großen, schwarzen Messerstecker dran gewarnt?
Messerstecker? Ja, das waren Europakarten.
Ja genau, dann musste man hinten so fette Stecker anstecken mit so fetten Krabeln. Die haben mit dem PA zusammen geschraubt.
Die haben mit dem PA zusammen geschraubt. Das war alles komplett. Ich hab da eine Frage, wo vor einer Stunde hattet ihr mal das Thema mit dem Telefon abhören und verfolgen die Rückrufe und so weiter. Wie ist denn der Fall, wenn ich eine automatische Weiterschaltung machen lasse, zum Beispiel auf den Apparat von der Firma, von meiner Firma meinetwegen, und da dann Anrufe und die Weiterschaltung schon zu eben, sagen wir mal jetzt, so genannten illegalen Anrufer mache, kann das dann auch weiter zurückverfolgt werden?
Das kann selbstverständlich weiter zurückverfolgt werden, weil ja, dein Anschluss, ja Moment, das ist hier ein Entwurf. Also der Andreas hält mir jetzt gerade ganz kurz die Richtlinie, diese Entwurfsrichtlinie vom Europäischen Parlament unter die Nase. Da steht das explizit drin, aber wir müssen gar nicht in die Zukunft gucken. Auch in der Gegenwart im Telekommunikationsgesetz sind derartige Rufumleitungen explizit erfasst. Und das heißt, das würde dir lediglich für den Fall etwas bringen, dass du von einem anderen, also einem anderen Teilnehmer zugehörigen Anschluss wieder rauswählst als von den Teilnehmerdaten, wo der Ruf rein geht.
Aber die Sachen sind trotzdem problemlos nachverfolgbar. Also die Rufumleitung ist keinerlei Schutz vor Abhören. Also da...
Ja, gut, das redet sich. Aber das eine ist eine ISDN oder eine vom Netz her konstruierte Rufumleitung. Also eine netzseitige Rufumleitung wird bei einer solchen Maßnahme automatisch registriert. Und entsprechend die Leitung wird verfolgt eine manuelle Rufumleitung im Sinne von du nimmst das Telefon sozusagen, du nimmst den Hörer in Anführungszeichen ab und wählst dann auf einer Leitung, die dir nicht zugeordnet werden kann, einen anderen Teilnehmer ab. Die verhindern zwar nicht, dass die Verbindung nicht abgehört werden kann. Das ist ja klar, weil sie läuft ja über die Leitung.
Aber die Rückverfolgung, von wem es kommt, das ist doch...
Nee, Moment, wenn du das verhindern willst, das ist eine ganz andere Geschichte. Da hast du erstmal keine Chance. Also nicht mit dieser Methode. Weil eine Rufumleitung heißt ja lediglich, dass sozusagen umgeleitet wird, wo es hingeht, und nicht umgeleitet wird, wo es herkommt.
Also Rufumleitung hilft dann in jedem Falle nicht. Also der einzige Weg tatsächlich noch anonym zu telefonieren, oder ist halt eine Münzertelefonzelle.
Ja, das ist klar. Ich meine bloß, wenn ich die Möglichkeit habe, von mir zu Hause den Rechner in meinem Betrieb zu programmieren, der automatisch bestimmte Rufnummern wählen kann. Und wenn ich den dann von mir aus anrufe, und dem dann eine Nummer eingebe, die man von mir aus verfolgen kann, aber nicht wissen soll, dass ich jetzt derjenige war, der in dieser Firma angerufen hat.
Na dann kommt mir halt einfach nach, welche Rufe zu dieser Zeit zu deiner Firma gingen.
Also auch das lässt sich... Ja, aber das lässt sich alles eingrenzen. Die Tools dafür sind automatisiert. Da sagt man, sag mir mal alle Telefongespräche, die in der Nähe der Zielrufnummer zur selben Zeit geführt wurden, und das mehr als einmal und dann...
Zu dem Verschlüsselungsproblem an sich hatte ich eigentlich eine grundsätzliche Frage. Weil ich meine, Ophatia Chaos Computer anbietet, diese Mailing-Listen zu verschlüsseln, und dann nicht die Liste, ja doch die Liste, und dann alle Teilnehmer wieder zu verschlüsseln. Ich meine, die Nachrichten selbst sind ja verschlüsselt, aber das ist doch dann schon wieder fast so was wie eine öffentliche Sache, wo alle, die sich eintragen, dann automatisch die Nachricht bekommen, die ja dann wieder entschlüsselt ist.
Das ist im Prinzip richtig, bloß stellen wir ja nicht nur eine Mailing-Liste zur Verfügung, die das tut, sondern wir geben sozusagen das Werkzeug, eigene Mailing-Listen zu verschlüsseln, raus. Und das heißt, dass du da ja durchaus in der Lage bist, Mailing-Listen zu machen, die eben nicht offen für jeden Subscriber, also eintragbar sind, sondern die eben einen geschlossenen Besitzerkreis...
Ich kann natürlich kontrollieren, wer dann in die Liste...
Typischerweise trägt man dann einen Moderator ein. An den gehen dann die Subscriptions und der entscheidet dann, ob er die reinnehmen will oder nicht.
Eigentlich so, wenn ich was wirklich Vertrauliches habe, dann ist es eigentlich auch unter vier Augen, sobald es mehr oder nur zwei Teilnehmer sind. Wenn es mehr sind, ist es schon wieder fast so wie öffentlich, dann lohnt sich auch eine Verschlüsselung nicht.
Das ist nicht richtig. Also die Verschlüsselung lohnt sich immer. Sie lohnt sich erstens schon deshalb, damit es nicht auffällt, wenn du wirklich mal was Geheimes verschlüsseln möchtest. Also wenn alle deine Mail verschlüsselt ist, ist es deutlich schwieriger festzustellen, dass du jetzt irgendwie was Wichtiges zu sagen hast. Zum zweiten ist es so, dass du ja... Okay, wenn dann mehrere Leute drin hast, dann ist es vielleicht schon halbwegs öffentlich. Aber zumindest hast du noch die Chance, den Informationsfluss in Kontrolle zu halten. Mit diesem Echelonsystem kann man ja automatisiert alle Datenübertragungen abhören. Das heißt, wenn da irgendwelche Stichworte drin vorkommen, dann landest du automatisch auf der Liste. Und wenn du den Mailverkehr, den Transitverkehr verschlüsselst, dann ist es natürlich nicht automatisch geheim, weil irgendjemand kann das immer noch weitergeben. Aber zumindest ist es nicht mehr von selber in Echtzeit in dem System drin.
Und dann noch zur Art und Weise, ihr empfehlt ja, möglichst Verschlüsselungsalgorithmen zu nehmen, die ausgiebig getestet sind und groß im Umlauf sind. Aber ich hab die persönliche Anlehnung, das ist nochmal mal eine einfache Textdatei. Die speichert eben im Format ab. Ein ganz altes Works-Format zum Beispiel, dann ist es als reine Textdatei auch nicht mehr so einfach zu lesen.
Oh, da gibt es das Nr.
minus Trinks unter Unix. Das ist nur der Anfang. Der Text selbst steht natürlich noch im Klartext drin, aber nicht mehr als reine Text, als die Datei.
Wenn da wirklich jemand ran will, wenn diese Datei auf deiner Platte liegt und du hast etwas Schlimmes getan und da steht drin, wie du es geplant hast, dann ist es mir völlig egal, ob das Works 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7 ist. Das kriege ich raus. Also da komme ich ran.
Das ist mir schon klar, aber wenn man jetzt mehrere Stufen nimmt und das Ganze pack ich dann wieder, was das ist, ich selbst dann pack eine AJ und dann nehme ich wieder ein Verschlüsselungs-Album.
Ja, aber das Ganze soll ja auch noch praktikabel sein, weil der Trick an diesen Verschlüsselungen ist ja, dass du eben auch Nachrichtenaustausch mit anderen Menschen betreiben kannst, ohne dass du dem auf einer Telefonleitung oder sonst wie die umständliche Prozedur erklären musst, sondern du schickst ihm eben dein Public Key und benutzt sein Public Key und ihr könnt Nachrichten austauschen und die sind verschlüsselt und auf jeden Fall tausendmal sicherer als jegliche Verschleierungsmethode mit irgendwelchen alten Textverarbeitungsprogrammen oder mit Komprimierungen oder irgendeinem Falsch.
Also es gibt da einen sehr schönen Begriff für Security, dieser Begriff bezeichnet Verfahren, bei denen die Sicherheit darauf beruht, dass irgendjemand etwas nicht weiß. Und wenn du deine Sicherheit darauf aufbaust, dass niemand weiß, dass du irgendwie eine, was weiß ich, Works-1-Datei mit AIJ-Verschlüssel dann noch gezippt hast und so weiter und so fort, dann hast du keine wirkliche Sicherheit, weil diese Information musst du irgendwie übermitteln an den Empfänger dieser Nachricht und wenn sie auf diesem Wege abgefangen wird, diese Informationen, dann hast du sozusagen deine Sicherheit.
Wie die Verschlüsselung der Datei nachher letztendlich aufgebaut ist, das muss ich ihm natürlich auch sagen.
Da hast du das Problem, dass du einen zweiten Kommunikationsweg brauchst. So und dieser zweite Kommunikationsweg ist der angreifbare. Deswegen empfehlen wir ja auch asymmetrische Verfahren, wo du von vornherein immer eine Trennung hast zwischen einem privaten und einem öffentlichen Teil und du nur gezwungen bist, deinen öffentlichen Teil zu veröffentlichen, damit andere Leute dir schon was schicken können, ohne dass du deinen geheimen Schlüssel damit preisgibst. Das ist der wesentliche Vorteil dieses Systems. Alle symmetrischen Verschlüsselungsverfahren haben eben genau dieses Problem, dass du eben erstmal den Schlüssel austauschen musst. Da gibt es zwar auch Methoden und bei SSL und so wird das ja auch überall gemacht, aber das ist eben nichts für eine Mail, wo sich jemand unter Umständen die Mühe macht, da einfach ein paar Tage daran umzurechnen.
Wollen wir nochmal ganz schnell versuchen, ob wir noch zwei, drei Fragen beantworten können auf kurze? Weil gleich ist Feierabend. Martin, danke erstmal. Wenn wir es wirklich schaffen, kurze Frage, kurze Antwort, dann schaffen wir noch ein paar Leute. Zum Beispiel den hier. Sehr kurz. Supi, das war schön gefragt. Hallo, wer ist denn da? Chaosradio hier.
Ja, hallo, Olaf ist mein Name. Ich hab nur eine Frage nochmal zu den, also Kommunikation über Telefon. Und zwar über Handy mit diesem Source Code. Ich bin nun nicht so bewandert in Sachen Internet und so ein Kram. Und darum hatte ich das ehrlich gesagt nicht so interessiert, aber weil ihr gesagt habt, wenn ich mal auf einer Kommunikationsmesse an den Stand gehe, wo ein Handyvertreter ist und den fragen soll nach dem Source Code, wie er genannt wird. Was ist das genau?
Also das Problem besteht darin, dass es ein Source Code ist. Die Frage ist eine ganz simple. Ja, darf ich mal kurz eine Antwort geben, in einer Wunderlage, deutsche Sätze zu sprechen? Wollen wir uns erstmal streiten? Nein, also ich würde jetzt gerne mal meinen Versuch eine Antwort kurz...
Ich sage erstmal, was es ist. Das Source Code ist nichts anderes als der Text, in dem der Programmierer seinen Code geschrieben hat. Das heißt, wenn man etwas programmiert, dann schreibt man Source Code, Quellcode, da wo sozusagen das Programm daraus hervorgeht. Das wird dann übersetzt in den tatsächlichen ausführbaren Codes, auch executable genannt. Und das ist das, was da drin ist.
Genau, und das Problem besteht eben darin, dass ein Mobiltelefon, wie vieles andere, auch eine Black Box ist. In Black Box heißt man weiß, was sie tut, oder man weiß nicht, was sie noch tut. Und um das eben nachzuvollziehen, was eigentlich in dem Gerät vor sich geht, braucht man den Source Code.
Na und, wenn ich den kriegen würde, was könnte ich damit anfangen? Was bringt man davon fort?
Du könntest den Leuten geben, die davon Ahnung haben, die könnten da reinschauen und können das analysieren. Zwangsläufig würde so ein Source Code schnell auf dem Netz sein, da würden sich den alle Leute sofort anschauen. Also angenommen, Nokia würde jetzt irgendwie ein Telefon rausbringen und sagen, okay, hier ist der ganze Source Code noch dazu, hätte das zwei Effekte. Effekt eins, der Source Code wäre binnen weniger Wochen komplett analysiert und es könnte eine klare Aussage darüber getroffen werden, was diese Software tatsächlich tut. Der zweite Effekt ist, dass relativ zielstrebig Fehler gefunden werden, die zwangsläufig da drin sind. Und ein dritter möglicher Effekt ist, dass die Software vielleicht weiterentwickelt wird und du sogar ein sehr viel besseres Telefon bald in der Hand hältst, ohne ein neues kaufen zu müssen.
Das ist ein System, das übrigens im Computerbereich, in vielen Betriebssystemen funktioniert und vieler Software. Mit anderen Worten, du kannst einfach nur, der Source Code bedeutet nur, dass Leute, die selber Programmierer sind, sich angucken können, wie funktioniert dieses Gerät, was passiert da wirklich, wie ist es programmiert. Und dann können sie sagen, das und das stimmt nicht, das können wir verbessern, oder hier und hier ist was drin, worüber wir nicht informiert waren vorher und so weiter und so fort.
Man könnte damit zum Beispiel die Frage beantworten, ob man mit einem Mobiltelefon, das auf dem Tisch liegt, abhören kann oder nicht.
Genau.
Aber wenn du dir nicht wirklich sicher bist, was Source Code ist und meint, dann solltest du die Leute vielleicht noch nicht fragen. Das wendet sich eher an die Leute, die schon wissen, was wir damit meinen. Aber wir empfehlen dir, dich ruhig noch ein bisschen damit zu beschäftigen, damit du sicher weißt, was ein Source Code ist.
Das macht auch Spaß.
Das kann man besser argumentieren. Außerdem ist es interessant, sich damit zu beschäftigen.
Ja, es macht wirklich Spaß. Man muss auch nicht Programmierer sein, um diese Sachen zu verstehen, finde ich. Man muss ja nicht jeder anfangen, Programmiersprachen zu lernen.
Ja, aber es hilft.
Ach, es gibt genug Leute, die es können.
Man sollte diesen Source Code einfach als Bestandteil des Produktes ansehen, weil man kriegt im Prinzip nur die Hälfte verkauft. Man kriegt eine Scheinfunktionalität, die einem versprochen wird. Wie oft hat man festgestellt, dass das technische Gerät, was ja angeblich kochen, die Freundin babysitten und solche Sachen, was das alles können soll, dass es das eigentlich gar nicht kann. Es gibt auch Leute, die tun das, ohne den Sourcecode zu haben. Die betreiben dann einfach Re-Engineering, das heißt, sie schließen viele lustige Kabel an das Telefon an und versuchen mit dem Prozessor zu reden und lassen sich dann einfach mal den Inhalt ausgeben und setzen das dann mit einigen Gehirnschmalz um. Das ist allerdings etwas für Freaks. Und hätte man den Sourcecode, dann wäre der Weg sozusagen sehr viel einfacher. Aber auch das wird getan. Es gibt durchaus Leute, die durch die Gegend laufen, wo eine Software auf dem Handy läuft, die du nicht im Laden kaufen kannst.
So, das war aber sicher eine Frage, die viele interessiert hat. Was ich ganz erstaunlich finde, am Ende dieser Sendung und bei den letzten Anrufern, ist, dass das Interesse im Bereich Telefonie doch extrem groß ist. Ist ja auch klar. Ist ja auch klar. Wenn es eins gibt, was wirklich weltumspannend ist, dann ist es, glaube ich, die Faszination, der, sagen wir mal zumindest, männlichen Weltbevölkerung an Handys. Wie gesagt, war in Spanien in so einem kleinen Rentner-Cuff irgendwie, aber wenn du eins siehst, was du überall auf der Welt siehst, egal wohin du gehst, vorausgesetzt, dass es die Dinger da gibt, und damit also nicht überall, aber alle rennen mit einem Handy rum irgendwie. Ja, mit einem Cellular-Phone. Oder mit einem, was haben sie noch? Oder weiß nicht, was es noch für Begriffe gibt. Vielleicht sollte man da auch noch mal eine Sendung drüber machen. Die wird garantiert, wenn überhaupt, dann im nächsten Jahr stattfinden, denn dann hören wir uns wieder. Ja, naja, Kryptographie hatten wir auch schon mal.
Ja, wir machen das auch wieder.
Wie viele Jahre gibt's denn jetzt Chaosradio eigentlich?
Überall dieses Thema erwartet ihr auch mehr auf dem Chaos Communication Kongress, der vom 27. bis 29. Dezember in Berlin im Haus am Kölnischen Park stattfindet. Informationen vorab gibt's unter www.ccc.de slash Kongress. Eine gute Nacht mit C. Eine gute Nacht mit C. Mit DZ wie Löwe.
Genau, und bevor eine die total durchdreht, sagen wir einfach Tschüss.
Ich lasse das Mikro noch ein bisschen auf für Andi. Du kannst ein paar Stunden hier bleiben.